Hey, what's going on is Bill Burr and I am in the waiting room waiting for the the three gentlemen will call them of the smart list podcast. It's funny they told me to be here by 845 even though the podcast starts at 930. So sort of a point of contention already. But this is the Smartless Podcast. Here we go. Here's the nice, you guys appreciate this. I decided I'm going to go to, I was hanging with our buddy at his house over in the West Village and then our other buddy, Chris Henshey showed up and we were chit chatting and Chris Henshey is always good for a million laughs.
嘿，最近怎么样，我是比尔·伯尔，我现在在候诊室里等待着《SmartLess》播客的三位绅士——我们姑且这么称呼他们。真搞笑，他们让我8点45分到，尽管播客9点30分才开始。所以这已经算是个有点争议的地方了。不过这就是《SmartLess》播客。我们开始吧。给你们听听这个，你们肯定会觉得有意思。我决定去，我之前在西村我们哥们儿家里闲逛，然后我们的另一个哥们儿克里斯·亨舍尔也来了，我们就闲聊起来，克里斯·亨舍尔总是能逗得大家哈哈大笑。
And I said, I'm going to go to Cafe Clooney for lunch solo. And he goes, oh, you got to have the Buffalo chicken dumplings. I go, where are these like they're dumplings, but they're in buffalo chicken sauce. I go, it's not part of my freaking diet. He's like, oh, my buddy runs up. I said, yeah, thanks, man. But you know, this is a temple, as JB would say. So I walk over.
我说，我要一个人去克鲁尼咖啡馆吃午饭。他说，哦，你得尝尝他们的水牛城鸡肉饺子。我说，这是什么东西，就像是饺子，但里面是水牛城鸡肉酱。我说，这可不在我的严格饮食计划里。他说，哦，我哥们儿在那经营。我说，行吧，谢谢啦，兄弟。不过你知道的，正如JB会说的，这是一个圣殿。所以我走过去了。
Body's no fluke. No fluke. And I walk over there, beautiful noon on a Monday, snow, just like heavy snow starting, tucked into a corner. I order a salad and a little bit of chicken with some veggies, that's it. And the waitress comes over, plunks down
身材绝对没话说。绝无水分。我走过去的时候，正值周一美丽的中午，雪，刚开始下那种大雪，我找了个角落坐下。我点了一份沙拉和一点带蔬菜的鸡肉，就这样。服务员走过来，啪地放下
some buffalo chicken dumplings. And I'm like, I text Ed Sheehan, I'm like, you motherfucker. Oh, he called ahead. He called it in. My buddy's sitting in the corner, can you deliver some? That's funny, and they were, did you have them? Yeah, I had two, they were delicious.
一些水牛城鸡肉饺子。我当时就想，我给埃德·希兰发短信说，你个混蛋。哦，他提前打电话了。他打电话预定的。我哥们儿坐在角落里，能送点过来吗？这太搞笑了，而且它们，你吃过吗？吃过，我吃了两个，太美味了。
They look like they had a lot of sodium in them. Do they? No, no, no, do they? No, they don't, you look too beautiful. Am I looking pot? I wanted to tell you about Ricky, what happened to Ricky, this is pretty wild. Gervais?
看起来里面的钠含量挺高的。是吗？不，不，不，是吗？不，没有，你看上去太美了。我看起来很胖吗？我想跟你讲讲瑞奇，瑞奇发生了什么事，这事挺离谱的。热维斯？
No, my dog. He got another special. Wait, did he lose a number? Is he bringing the office back? What's happening? I Love that. We always go to you for our Ricky Gervais news. You're always up on what Ricky's up to Tracy Ricky is my dog Yeah, she knows that
不，我的狗。他又拍了一部特辑。等等，他少了一个数字吗？他要把《办公室》带回来？怎么回事？我太喜欢了。我们总是找你打听瑞奇·热维斯的新闻。你总是对瑞奇的动向了如指掌。特蕾西，瑞奇是我的狗。对，她知道这件事。
So he was being watched by this friend of ours who watches a lot of dogs and whatever. And one of the dogs that this person was watching has to take Prozac, right? Oh, sure, of course. It's Los Angeles' dog. Yes, California. Yeah.
所以他当时由我们的一个朋友照看，这个朋友经常帮人看狗什么的。而且这个人照顾的其中一只狗必须吃百忧解，对吧？哦，当然，肯定的。洛杉矶的狗嘛。是的，加州。对。
Lots of problems in the world, but California dogs need any depressants. It's pretty stressful. It drops from 68 to 72 without any warning. You can bail out now if you want, by the way. No, no, it's okay. Okay, you're in deep. No, I'm almost done.
世界上有那么多问题，但加州的狗狗需要抗抑郁药。这压力挺大的。没有预兆气温就从68度跌到72度。顺便说一句，如果你想的话，现在可以跳车。不，不，没关系。好吧，你陷得很深。不，我快说完了。
Yeah, you're waist deep. So she gives the dog his one Prozac and she puts the bottle on the counter and Ricky jumps up, knocks it over and eats 10 of them. 10 Prozac, I'm not kidding. And so it's such a long story, but we had to take them to the vet and blah, blah, blah, and they'd make him throw up or whatever.
对，你已经深陷其中了。所以她给那只狗喂了一颗百忧解，把药瓶放在柜台上，瑞奇跳了上去，把它撞翻了，然后吃了10颗。10颗百忧解，我没开玩笑。这故事说来话长，但我们不得不带它去兽医那里，巴拉巴拉的，他们让它把药吐出来什么的。
And I'm talking to the vet and I'm like, what's the deal? And he's like, well, there's 50-50 chance. I'm like, that he's gonna die? He goes, yeah. Like so matter of fact. And I was like, I kind of appreciated that he said it's so cavalier, but I was also like, bedside manner was really bad. Anyway, and then the story is he's all good.
我在跟兽医说话，我问，到底什么情况？他说，嗯，有百分之五十的几率。我说，它会死吗？他说，对。就这么轻描淡写。我当时一方面挺欣赏他这么漫不经心地说出来的，但另一方面我也觉得，他的医生态度真的太差了。总之，后来结果是它完全没事。
I said to Sean, I said I thought he was going to say that Ricky ate 10 Prozac and joined up with people. You know, like just got real positive and started touring the world, just bringing joy to everybody, you know? Yeah. All right, so let's get to the guest. Okay. My guest today is a fellow podcaster so let's get to the guest. Okay.
我对肖恩说，我以为他会说瑞奇吃了10颗百忧解之后跑去加入人群了。你知道的，就那种变得超级积极，开始世界巡演，给每个人带来欢乐，你知道吗？对。好了，那我们来请出嘉宾吧。好的。我今天的嘉宾也是一位播客同行，所以我们来请出嘉宾吧。好的。
My guest today is a fellow podcaster. He's one of the funniest people alive. A Boston native. He's a passionate Patriots fan. He's one of the few comedians to sell at Madison Square Garden, London's Royal Albert Hall. And two years ago, he made history as the first comedian to ever perform at Fenway Park.
我今天的嘉宾也是一位播客同行。他是世上最搞笑的人之一。波士顿本地人。他是狂热的爱国者队球迷。他是极少数能在麦迪逊广场花园和伦敦皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅门票售罄的喜剧演员之一。两年前，他创造了历史，成为首位在芬威球场表演的喜剧演员。
Our listeners have seen him in one of his eight billion brilliant comedy specials or live tours. Did Will get it? Did Will get what? Did I say Bill Burr? He said Bill Burr. I don't know, maybe.
我们的听众一定在或者他那八十亿个精彩的喜剧特辑或现场巡演中见过他。威尔接上茬了吗？威尔接了什么？我刚才说比尔·伯尔了吗？他说比尔·伯尔了。不知道，可能吧。
And he's been on my smart list. He's got a sing, get over here, it's fucking intro. It's the hilarious Bill Burr! What? Alright, it's Bill Burr. Hey, what's up guys? Hey, so sorry about the delay. We've been having all those tech issues.
而且他一直都在我的SmartLess名单上。他得有首歌，过来吧，这该死的开场白。他就是搞笑的比尔·伯尔！什么？好吧，这就是比尔·伯尔。嘿，大家好！嘿，真不好意思耽误了。我们刚才遇到了一堆技术问题。
Oh, I was just enjoying the podcast. About dogs with Prozac. I mean, how would you know the dog gets depressed? I mean, it doesn't... I know, I don't know. What did it talk to you about? What was it? Was it the way it played with the ball?
哦，我刚才正听着播客呢。关于吃百忧解的狗。我是说，你怎么会知道那只狗抑郁了呢？我是说，它不……我懂，我不知道。它跟你聊过吗？那是怎样？是因为它玩球的方式吗？
Well, I wasn't watching the one that needed it, but I imagine the same thing. Like, how do you... Oh, you needed Prozac and the dog ate it. No, a different dog had the. Different dog had a dog Prozac. You were listening to a different podcast, Bill, I think. Hey, this is what I would think.
好吧，我看的不是那只需要吃药的狗，但我猜也差不多。就好像，你怎么……哦，你需要的百忧解结果让狗给吃了。不，是另一只狗吃了。另一只狗吃了狗狗专用的百忧解。比尔，我觉得你听的是另一个播客。嘿，我是这么想的。
Sounds to me like you got up-sold by that vet. It does. It does, huh? From Milk Bones to fucking Prozac. I would venture to say that there are, in the same way that they say that people look like their dogs, I bet you it's a little bit of sort of projection from the owner,
听起来像是那个兽医向你推销了更贵的东西。确实。确实是，对吧？从磨牙骨到他妈的百忧解。我敢说，就像人们常说狗长得像主人一样，我打赌这其实是主人的一种心理投射，
like my dog needs Prozac. Like, does your dog need Prozac? Or do you? Or does Scotty? Now, just hold on a second here. This is a huge booking. I know, Bill. You know, Bill.
比如我的狗需要百忧解。就像，你的狗真的需要百忧解吗？还是你需要？或者斯科蒂需要？现在，等一下。这是一次重磅预约。我知道，比尔。你知道的，比尔。
Bill Burr. You don't need to do this shit. What do you, does Sean have some? Believe me, when you kept losing your internet, I was thinking about that. I was like, how is this helping me? No, it did help my relationship. I got out of the house, which gives my wife
比尔·伯尔。你不需要搞这些破事。怎么，肖恩身上带了点？相信我，当你的网络一直断线时，我就在想这个。我当时就在想，这对我有什么帮助？不，这确实对我的关系有帮助。我离开了家，这让我妻子
a break from me, which is always nice. Do you find that? I find that my relationship is better when I'm working out of town. Yeah, when I'm not there, we get along great. It's when I'm home. And then do you feel stressed to pick up the phone every night and talk, well, what did you do today?
能从我身边喘口气，这总是挺好的。你有这种感觉吗？我发现当我出差在外时，我和伴侣的关系会更好。对，当我不在的时候，我们相处得极好。只有在我回家的时候。然后你是不是会觉得压力很大，每天晚上都要打电话聊天，问句：你今天做了什么？
Here's what I did today. Or are you comfortable going a couple of days without talking if there's not really something to really discuss? No, I don't do that, no, but I just try to make her laugh. So I just call up and just be a goofball, lighten up the mood, you know? Your humor still works for her? Yeah, it actually does.
我今天做了这些。或者如果没有什么真正需要讨论的事情，你能不能安稳地过几天不说话的日子？不，我不那样，不，但我只是想逗她笑。所以我只是打个电话当个活宝，活跃一下气氛，你知道吗？你的幽默对她还管用吗？对，其实挺管用的。
My wife has a great sense of humor. She's actually, believe it or not, I think she's funnier than a lot of comedians I know. Like she's like hilarious, so. Well, that's not hard. Yeah, Sam and Scotty, yeah. That's not hard. Yeah, Sam Scottie, yeah. That's not hard. But let me ask you this, and Jason,
我妻子很有幽默感。她其实，信不信由你，我觉得她比我认识的很多喜剧演员都幽默。她真的超级搞笑，所以。那倒不难。对，萨姆和斯科蒂，对。那倒不难。对，萨姆·斯科蒂，对。那倒不难。不过我问你个问题，杰森，
you was very revealing the way you answered that question. Do you feel the pressure to call every night? That seems like, do you want to elaborate on that? Yeah. Wait, let me snort a Prozac. Well yeah, we're 25 years into this thing, and the kids don't want to talk to me, and so it really just leaves the wife,
你回答那个问题的方式非常暴露内心。你觉得每天晚上打电话有压力吗？这听起来像，你想详细说说吗？对。等等，让我吸一口百忧解。好吧，是的，我们在一起25年了，孩子们也不想跟我说话，所以最后真的就剩下老婆了，
and if I don't have something that is really pressing to share, then sometimes we'll just be on the phone, we'll just hang there, and then we feel the stress of having to come up with some shit to say, and then, you know, so, no, yeah, no. We don't really call unless there's a hot topic or a hot take. So it's basically sort of a business relationship
如果我没有什么特别紧迫的事情要分享，有时我们在电话里就会那么干耗着，然后我们就会感到必须编点屁话来说的压力，然后，你知道的，所以，不，对，不。除非有什么热门话题或犀利观点，否则我们一般不打电话。所以基本上这就变成了一种商务关系，
at this point, you know? Yes, yeah. We'll set up a Zoom. Right. Yeah. I talked to her assistant, she says she's got something pressing, and can I make some time between three and four?
到了这个阶段，你知道吗？是的，对。我们会安排一个Zoom会议。对。对。我跟她的助理沟通过，她说她有紧急事情要谈，问我能不能在三点到四点之间腾出点时间？
No, I love talking to my wife, she's hilarious. Good for you. Wait, do you guys have kids? Wait, Jason, hang on, one more time, and Jason, there's still room for you to go, I love my wife too, and we'll edit it, we'll close the gap. Oh, I must have cut out again, I said that pretty emphatically. I believed it, I heard it on my end.
不，我很喜欢跟我老婆聊天，她太搞笑了。那可真好。等等，你们有孩子吗？等等，杰森，等一下，再来一次，杰森，你其实还可以补上一句“我也很爱我老婆”，我们会剪辑一下，把中间的空白连起来。哦，我肯定又断线了，我刚才说得非常有感情来着。我相信，我在我这边听到了。
I love her so much. Bill, so I knew it was you when Sean did the intro and the blind intro because I knew that you'd sold out Madison Square Garden and I knew that you'd sold out Royal Albert Hall because I saw you at Royal Albert Hall on one of your shows there. Notes? If you remember a few years back.
我太爱她了。比尔，所以当肖恩做开场白和盲开场时，我就知道是你了，因为我知道你的麦迪逊广场花园门票卖光了，我也知道你的皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅门票卖光了，因为我在你那里的演出上见过你。笔记？如果你还记得几年前的话。
Fucking unbelievable. Yeah, always. Honestly, it was really impressive and you know, Bill, I'm not going to go crazy, but you know that I'm a few years back, fucking unbelievable. Yeah, always been. Honestly, it was really impressive. And you know, Bill, I'm not going to go crazy, but you know that I'm a fan, and I have been following Tom. Why would he know that? You write him letters?
太他妈难以置信了。对，一直都是。说实话，这真的很让人印象深刻，而且你知道的，比尔，我不会疯狂，但你知道我是几年前的事了，太他妈难以置信了。对，一直如此。说实话，这真的很令人印象深刻。而且你知道的，比尔，我不会发疯，但你知道我是个粉丝，而且我一直关注着汤姆。他怎么会知道？你给他写过信吗？
Well, he knows that. We know each other a little bit. And I went to see him, and it was unbelievable, sold out royal. It was so impressive, and it was so awesome. Listen, Bill, I didn't come here for this. I know you didn't, but I want to say this. I'm not going to sit here and get complimented
好吧，他知道的。我们稍微认识一点。我去看过他的演出，那真是不可思议，皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅的票全卖光了。太令人印象深刻了，太棒了。听着，比尔，我来这可不是为了这个。我知道你不是，但我想说这个。我才不会坐在这里听人夸奖
for fucking hours. Well, it's also rare. Don't point it. It's always, I'll do whatever the fuck I want. You're a Bruins fan. I'll treat you like one. Maple Leafs knocked the crap out of the Bruins last night, was it?
整整他妈的好几个小时。好吧，这也是难得一见。别指出来。不管怎样，我想干什么他妈的就干什么。你是个棕熊队球迷。我就把你当棕熊队球迷对待。枫叶队昨晚把棕熊队打得落花流水，是吧？
Yeah, good for it. It was Saturday night. Well, this is their time of year. You know? January. They crush us. And also the first three games of a seven game series. You do not want any part of the Toronto Maple Leafs.
对，活该。那是周六晚上。好吧，这就是他们一年的这个时候。你知道吗？一月份。他们把我们压制得死死的。而且七场四胜制的前三场比赛。你绝对不想跟多伦多枫叶队扯上任何关系。
Those last four though. Nothing but smooth sailing. Jesus fucking Christ. Don't laugh Sean. What the hell's going on. I don't, but I figured it out. It's a little bit true and I love Paul. A little bit true, it's been 57 years.
不过最后那四场。简直是一帆风顺。操他妈的耶稣。别笑，肖恩。这到底是怎么回事。我不会，但我琢磨明白了。这有点符合事实，而且我很爱保罗。有点符合事实，已经57年了。
Yeah, it has been 57 years, but we're building because we like drama, okay? We could be like you guys and be fucking one and done. You guys haven't won since you won back in 2008 or whatever no 2011 yeah century last decade fine. I haven't won since Lyndon Johnson You haven't won since before we faked a lunar landing I knew it I Forgot that you're also a conspiracy theorist. I forgot like an artist.
对，确实是57年了，但我们在积蓄力量，因为我们喜欢戏剧性，好吧？我们可不像你们那样一轮游。你们自打2008年还是什么时候赢了之后就再没赢过，哦不，是2011年，对，上个世纪，上个十年，好吧。我自打林登·约翰逊以来就没赢过。你们自打我们伪造登月之前就没赢过。我就知道。我忘了你也是个阴谋论者。我忘了，就像个艺术家一样。
They were still playing with straight sticks. They didn't have the, Stan Makita hadn't figured it out yet. Straight sticks. Now did you ever play hockey? Goalie didn't have a mask. Did you play? Old Curly Johnson between the pipes tonight. And a young Will Arnett.
他们当时还在用直杆曲棍球杆。他们还没有，斯坦·麦基塔当时还没琢磨出来呢。直杆。话说你打过冰球吗？今晚镇守龙门的是老柯利·约翰逊。还有一个年轻的威尔·阿奈特。
Alright, let's get off, sorry. Sean, first question for your guest. I have a ton. old Curly Johnson between the pipes tonight and a young Will Arnett. All right, let's get off, sorry. Sean, first question for your guest. I have a ton. Well, I don't know you, Bill. Well, first of all, just a comment, it's not a thing. I saw you, the first time I think I ever met you was at Ted Sarandos' house sometime last year at this comedy dinner thing.
好了，我们换个话题，抱歉。肖恩，给你嘉宾的第一个问题。我有一大堆。今晚镇守龙门的是老柯利·约翰逊，还有一个年轻的威尔·阿奈特。好了，不扯这个了，抱歉。肖恩，请问你对嘉宾的第一个问题。我有一大堆。好吧，我其实不了解你，比尔。好吧，首先，只是个评论，这不算个事。我看到你，我第一次见你大概是在去年某个时候特德·萨兰多斯的家里，在一个喜剧晚宴上。
And you were one of the good guys. Yeah, the medieval man one of the good guys. The medieval manner. Yeah. Yeah. It's a total medieval manner. I always feel like when I go there at some point, all our AI replacements are gonna come up out of the base. For approval.
你是个好人。对，中世纪庄园里的大好人。中世纪庄园。对。对。完全就是个中世纪庄园。我总觉得我去那里的某个时刻，我们所有的AI替代品都会从地下室里爬出来。等待批准。
Kill their human versions. Like AI Dave Chappelle's gonna come up. Gotcha, bitch. Well, for my sister, Tracy Tedstrand, was just the head of Netflix. But anyway, so we were there, and I'd never met you before, and the first thing you said was, I had something in my teeth,
消灭它们的真人版本。比如AI版的戴夫·查佩尔会走出来说：抓到你了，碧池。好吧，为了我妹妹，特蕾西·特德斯特兰德，她刚刚卸任网飞负责人。不过总之，我们在那里，我以前从没见过你，你对我说第一句话是，我牙齿里有东西，
I had a piece of food in my teeth, and I didn't even say anything, and I handed you, I think, like a sugar packet, and you just went right in there, stuck your finger in my mouth, and you just got it out, and you handed you, I think like a sugar packet, and you just went right in there, stuck your finger in my mouth, and you just got it out. And you were like, oh, this guy's really cool. Solid. I wasn't going to let you walk around looking like that.
我牙齿里卡了一块食物，我甚至都没开口，你就递给我，我猜是个糖包什么的，然后你直接把手伸过来，把手指伸进我嘴里，直接把它掏出来了，你递给我，我猜是个糖包什么的，然后你直接把手伸过来，把手指伸进我嘴里，直接把它掏出来了。当时我就想，哦，这家伙真酷。靠谱。我才不想让你顶着那副尊容到处走呢。
I know. Because everyone was talking about you at that point, Sean. You'd had enough. Yeah, for sure. Somebody had... I wanted to be on the right side of history. You know, guys, I've been out here in LA long enough, and I just felt like, you know, I needed to be on the right side of history. You know, guys, I've been out here in LA long enough, and I just felt like, you know, I needed to tap into my inner hero.
我懂。因为当时每个人都在谈论你，肖恩。你已经受够了。对，肯定的。有人……我想站在历史正确的一边。你知道的，伙计们，我在洛杉矶混得够久了，我只是觉得，你知道的，我需要站在历史正确的一边。你知道的，伙计们，我在洛杉矶混得够久了，我只是觉得，你知道的，我需要唤醒内心的英雄主义。
How long have you been out, how long have you been in Los Angeles? Since 2007. Oh, I didn't know you lived here. Damn, I love it out here. I love it out here, and I like reading natives of Los Angeles because they love Los Angeles
你出来多久了，你在洛杉矶待多久了？从2007年开始。哦，我不知道你住在这里。天哪，我喜欢这里。我喜欢这里，而且我喜欢阅读洛杉矶本地人的作品，因为他们热爱洛杉矶，
and they know the history of it. And I just can't meet another stupid fucking New Yorker that is bitching about how much they fucking hate it and everybody's so real in New York. Like nobody lies on Wall Street. Everybody's just, you know, contractor says it's going to take two weeks in New York. He's done in 13 days.
而且他们了解洛杉矶的历史。我可不想再遇到另一个愚蠢的纽约混蛋，整天抱怨他妈的有多恨这里，抱怨纽约每个人都那么真实。就好像华尔街没有人撒谎一样。每个人都，你知道的，纽约的承包商说要两周完工。结果13天就搞定了。
It's so fucking stupid. And then the worst traveled people ever, New Yorkers, they get so freaked out. Like they go to Hong Kong and be like, let me get a bacon, egg, and cheese, and then they couldn't get it. This fucking place sucks. What's the point of traveling
太他妈愚蠢了。然后纽约人是最不会旅行的群里，他们总是大惊小怪的。比如他们去到香港，然后说：给我来个培根鸡蛋奶酪三明治，结果买不到。这个破地方太烂了。去旅行有什么意义，
if everything's going to be different? I love, Bill, I'm so with you, I'm glad you're banging this drum. They come out here, dude, they give up on their dream to make it in this business, because they don't like the pizza. Yeah, exactly. And then they go, in New York,
如果到处都跟家里不一样的话？比尔，我太赞同你了，我很高兴你在敲响这个警钟。他们来到这里，老兄，他们为了在这行出人头地而放弃了梦想，因为他们不喜欢这里的披萨。对，没错。然后他们会说，在纽约，
we get to walk around everywhere. I'm like, fuck it, then get out of your car and walk around. I'm not stopping you from fucking walking around. Should they fuck up? And also, you still go to New York? They're homesick, they're pussies, they're pussies, and they act like they're tough, because there are tough people in New York, but not you, you're homesick. They're homesick. They're pussies. They're pussies. And they act like they're tough because there are tough people in New York, but not you. You're an actor. You're doing a soliloquy. All right?
我们到处都可以步行。我就想，操，那你从车里下来到处走啊。我又没拦着你他妈的走路。他们是不是脑子进水了？而且，你还经常回纽约吗？他们想家，他们是懦夫，都是懦夫，还装得好像自己很硬气一样，因为纽约确实有狠人，但不是你，你想家了。他们想家了。他们是懦夫。他们是懦夫。还装得好像自己很硬气一样，因为纽约确实有狠人，但不是你。你只是个演员。你在念独白。行了吧？
Let's not act like you grew up in Brownsville with Mike Tyson. You did. And they're standing outside shivering like crazy saying, isn't New York great? Is New York great? LA sucks. Oh, and here's the last thing that drives me up the wall about New Yorkers. They think that Frank Sinatra song, New York, New York's great, LA sucks. LA sucks. That drives me up the wall about New Yorkers. They think that Frank Sinatra's song, New York, New York is about them. It's not about growing up in New York with the support system.
别装得好像你是在布朗斯维尔跟迈克·泰森一起长大的一样。你根本没有。他们站在外面冻得瑟瑟发抖，嘴里还念叨着：纽约难道不棒吗？纽约棒吗？洛杉矶太烂了。哦，还有最后一件事让我对纽约人抓狂。他们以为弗兰克·辛纳屈那首歌《纽约，纽约》是在夸他们棒，洛杉矶太烂了。洛杉矶太烂了。这事太让我对纽约人抓狂了。他们以为弗兰克·辛纳屈的歌《纽约，纽约》写的是他们。那首歌写的根本不是在纽约有靠山长大，
It's about not knowing anybody there and moving there. Right, yeah. It's not growing up and you got your mother here, your dad over there and you get to go home like, show business was mean to me today and they rubbed your fucking head. It's about going there and you don't know anybody. Like Frank, Frank Sinatra was bridge and tunnel.
而是写了在那里举目无亲、初来乍到的感觉。对，没错。那不是那种你从小在妈咪身边长大、爸爸在旁边照应、受了委屈能回家拍拍脑袋说“娱乐圈今天对我很残酷”然后被安慰的情形。写的是你到那儿去的时候谁也不认识。就像弗兰克，弗兰克·辛纳屈就是个“桥梁与隧道”通勤族。
Came in from New Jersey, then he had hits, and then they fucking claimed him. Steinbrenner was from fucking Cleveland, Ohio. I'm telling you, a lot of the shit that happens in there is from other people. And the rest of them. Bill, you ever think about getting a car with like a loudspeaker on the top
从新泽西来的，后来红了，然后他们这群人就开始把功劳往自己身上揽。斯坦布雷纳还是来自俄亥俄州克利夫兰呢。我跟你说，那里面发生的好多破事都是外地人干的。剩下的那些也是。比尔，你有没有想过买辆车，车顶装个大喇叭，
and driving around town? That would be good for you. I don't have to, I do stand up. No, but this might be more of the people, like you could just give it to people on the street. Hey you, you fucking missing, you think the fucking Yankees had off. You haven't even done a Yankees game in 12 years,
然后开车满城转悠？这对你挺合适的。我用不着，我做单口喜剧。不，但这可能更能直接接触群众，比如你可以直接冲大街上的人喊。嘿，你个白痴，你觉得洋基队轮休了。你已经12年没看洋基队的比赛了，
you know what I mean? That's a big misnomer, am I using that right, that people think that I walk around doing that shit. I don't. I only do it when it's done to me. So I've had it, I've had it. Like I lived in New York City during the height of the stupid Curse of the Babe thing,
你知道我的意思吧？这是一个很大的误导——我是不是用对词了？——人们以为我整天到处找茬。我才没有。我只有在别人先找我茬的时候才这么干。所以我是被逼的，我是被逼的。就像我在全盛时期的纽约市生活时，正值那个愚蠢的“贝比诅咒”甚嚣尘上的时候，
which was just always all bullshit. What's that? What's that? It was this fairy tale that white people made up because we didn't want to admit that the Red Sox didn't integrate till like 1992. And that's why we couldn't win. Because we traded some fat fuck like during World War I and if you do that,
那纯粹是一堆废话。那是什么？那是什么？那是有钱的白人群体编出来的一个童话故事，因为我们不想承认红袜队直到1992年左右才招收黑人球员。这才是我们赢不了球的原因。因为我们在第一次世界大战期间交易掉了一个胖子，如果你这么做了，
all of a sudden you're not, I mean at some point, when are you going to take responsibility that you had an all white team right through the mid 60s? Right? Oh my God, wait, but that, I don't want to talk about something that you're probably so sick of talking about, but I didn't know this until I watched it just recently the Philly incident thing So if you don't want to talk about we don't have to talk about it, but I I don't know about it
突然之间你就不是了——我是说，到了某个时候，你什么时候才能承担起责任，承认你们从60年代中期一直都是全白人球队？对吧？哦天哪，等等，不过这个，我不想谈论一个你可能已经听吐了的话题，但我直到最近才看到费城那次事件的视频，所以我如果不谈的话我们也可以不谈，但我我不知道这件事。
Okay, she told me she was of age So Jay he he was in Philadelphia and he was doing stand-up and right away No, no, no, no, not for here, not for here. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, audience so hard and for so long and he was counting the minutes on and by the way you ended that whole rant in Philly with all of you go fuck yourselves in your own assholes well I wanted to make sure it was consensual I've got to see this it's 14 minutes of him non-stop berating the audience and I was crying because of one heckler got after you? No, well, no, the guy kept going and going. It was this radio show, the Opie and Anthony show,
好吧，她告诉我她已经成年了……所以杰——他当时在费城表演单口喜剧，立刻——不，不，不，不，不是为了这事，不是为了这事。不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，你不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不客气地痛骂了观众很久，而且他在倒计时……顺便说一句，你在费城那场咆哮的结尾是“你们所有人去操翻你们自己的屁眼吧”。嗯，我是为了确保这是双方自愿的。我得去看看这个。那是长达14分钟的滔滔不绝痛骂观众，我当时都笑哭了。因为有个起哄者缠上了你？不，嗯，不，那家伙没完没了地挑衅。当时是个广播节目，《奥皮与安东尼秀》，
one of the big breaks I had in my career. Opie, Anthony and Jimmy Norton got me on that show, and that's when I first started selling tickets. So they had a bunch of comics on there, the late great Patrice O'Neill, Voss, Bobby Kelly, all of these guys. And they decided to do a stand-up tour. And it was, you know, sort of a Howard Stern style show, so you knew it was going to be
那是我职业生涯中最大的转机之一。奥皮、安东尼和吉米·诺顿让我上了那个节目，也就是从那时起我开始能卖出演出票了。所以当时他们节目上有一堆喜剧演员，已故的伟大帕特里斯·奥尼尔、沃斯、鲍比·凯利，所有这些人都去了。然后他们决定搞一个单口喜剧巡演。而且那是个，你知道的，有点像霍华德·斯特恩风格的节目，所以你心里清楚那肯定会是
a hostile crowd. So we were doing this tour, and we kind of knew the Philly show was coming. We just didn't know which city it was going to be. We knew it was going to happen. So it was, we showed up, I forget where it was, it was right across Camden, New Jersey. It was a long time ago and the fucking Philly people, they were like tailgating.
一个充满敌意的观众群体。所以我们在进行这次巡演，我们其实知道费城站迟早要来。我们只是不知道会是哪一个城市。我们知道这事一定会发生。所以我们到了现场，我忘了具体是在哪了，就在新泽西州卡姆登的对面。那是很久以前的事了，那些他妈的费城人，他们居然在搞露营尾门派对。
They had like Elio's jerseys on throwing footballs. It was fucking wild. It looked like it was either going to be a football game or a metal show. So the first guy went up and got booed. Oh God, it was so bad. The son was still out and he was from Philly and he had half his family there.
他们穿着埃利奥的球衣在扔橄榄球。太他妈疯狂了。那阵势看起来要么像一场橄榄球赛，要么像一场金属音乐节。所以第一个上台的家伙就被嘘了。天哪，太惨了。当时太阳还没落山，他是费城本地人，还有半个家族的人在现场。
It was so fucking bad. They were all chanting, asshole, asshole. And I remember, he didn't know what to do. He was like there in the headlights, and as it going, asshole, asshole, he just goes, thanks a lot, you guys have been great. And I went on like, you know, a couple hours after that and the sun had gone down and I made a few mistakes
简直糟糕透顶。他们全场都在高喊“混蛋，混蛋”。我记得，他当时完全不知所措。他就像呆若木鸡一样，在全场“混蛋，混蛋”的喊声中，他居然说了句：“谢谢大家，你们太棒了。”然后我在那之后大概几小时才上场，太阳已经落山了，我在开场时犯了几个错误，
getting into it and then they got on me and they all started booing. It's Philly. What does a mistake look like? I think I went out there, I was worried, so I was timid, so I was on my heel and you know, the crowd subconsciously senses that and then I also think I might have done,
然后他们就盯上了我，开始全场嘘我。这就是费城。犯错是什么样子的？我想我当时走上台时很担心，所以表现得很胆怯，重心落在脚后跟上，你知道的，观众潜意识里能察觉到这一点。然后我觉得我可能还，
started to do a bit and I was like, wait a minute, I think they played this bit on the radio and then I got in my head. And you know, the crowd subconsciously senses that. And then I also think I might have done, started to do a bit, and I was like, wait a minute, I think they played this bit on the radio, and then I got in my head, did they already know this joke? So I was sort of like a half-click behind was like 10,000 people booing me. But then I just started trashing their sports teams and that's what saved me. And them. Well it was because it was the tri-state area.
刚开始讲一个段子，然后我在想：等等，我怎么觉得这个段子他们在广播里放过了？然后我开始胡思乱想。你知道的，观众潜意识里能察觉到这一点。然后我觉得我可能还刚开始讲一个段子，然后我在想：等等，我怎么觉得这个段子他们在广播里放过了？然后我开始胡思乱想：他们是不是已经听过这个笑话了？所以我当时反应慢了半拍，身后是整整一万人在嘘我。不过后来我开始狂骂他们的运动球队，正是这一招救了我。还有他们自己。好吧，那是因为那是三州地区。
So there was, if I made fun of the Flyers, it was Devils fans and Capitals fans. So I got pockets of people laughing. Hitting everybody. And this was before the Phillies won another World Series. So they had won like one World Series in a hundred years. And then they also did a bunch of dumb shit, like put up a statue of Rocky but not Joe Frazier,
所以现场有，如果我取笑飞人队，现场就会有恶魔队球迷和首都队球迷。所以我能听到一小撮人在笑。谁都骂。而且那是在费城人队赢得下一次世界大赛之前。所以他们当时是一百年里只赢过一次世界大赛。而且他们还干了一堆蠢事，比如立了一尊洛奇的雕像却不立乔·弗雷泽的，
like they put one up of a fake white boxer. So it was pretty easy. I've never watched it, I'll be honest with you. I never watched it. I was riding home with Bobby Kelly, one of my great friends in this business, and I was just quiet. I had like a fucking headache.
他们居然给一个虚构的白人拳击手立雕像。所以这实在太好嘲讽了。老实说，我从来没看过那个视频。我当时跟鲍比·凯利一起坐车回家，他是我在这行里最好的朋友之一，我一路上都没怎么说话。我他妈头疼得要命。
And it did the opposite, by the way. It became viral and you became huge from that. Not that you weren't. No, but I didn't know how people were going to take it on the internet. I thought they were just going to watch it and see me getting booed, and I thought everyone was going to make fun.
顺便说一句，结果完全相反。这视频病毒式传播了，你也因此名声大噪。倒不是说你之前不出名。不，但我不知道互联网会怎么看待这个。我以为他们看了只会看到我被嘘，我以为所有人都会来嘲笑我。
You know, I could testify. So we were driving back up whatever that highway is, and I remember Bobby was going, he's like, You know, I was so good. I was so good. I was so good. I was so good. I was so good. I was so good. I was so good. I was so good. I was so good. I was so good. I was so good. I was so good.
我可以作证。我们当时正沿着不管是哪条高速公路开车往回走，我记得鲍比一直在说，他当时说：“你知道吗，我太棒了。我太棒了。我太棒了。我太棒了。我太棒了。我太棒了。我太棒了。我太棒了。我太棒了。我太棒了。我太棒了。我太棒了。”
I was so good. I was so good. I was so good. I was so good. I was so good. I was so good. I was so good. I was so good.
我太棒了。我太棒了。我太棒了。我太棒了。我太棒了。我太棒了。我太棒了。我太棒了。
I was so good. I was so good. I was so good. I was so good. I was so good. I was that, like that was going to be my thing. Because no one knew who I was, and this was my first big viral thing, and it wasn't me doing material, it was me getting booed. And then I did the next city on the tour, and I was walking around backstage, and people in the crowd saw me, and they were going boo before I even went out there.
我觉得，这将会成为我的标志。因为当时没人认识我，这是我第一个大火的病毒式视频，而且视频内容不是我在表演段子，而是我被嘘。后来我去巡演的下一个城市，我在后台走动时，台下的观众看到我，还没等我上台就冲我喊起嘘声了。
Oh geez. So I remember I was talking to those guys going, guys, you got to put me on early, you got to give me a chance, and they were going boo before it even went out there. Oh, geez. So I remember I was talking to those guys going, guys, you got to put me on early. You got to give me a chance. And they didn't. They put me on late. And I walked out and they just started booing me. And I was just like, guys, I'm not going to do this.
哦天哪。所以我记得我当时跟他们说：“伙计们，你们得让我早点上场，你们得给我个机会，”然而他们甚至还没等我上台就开始嘘我。哦，天哪。所以我记得我当时跟他们说：“伙计们，你们得让我早点上场。你们得给我个机会。”但他们没有。他们让我压轴上场。我走上台，他们就开始嘘我。我当时就想：“伙计们，我不干了。
I'm not going to do this. And then it was funny. They were like hitting me up on MySpace. This is how long it was. People of Cleveland being like, dude, there could have been such a great momin' in comedy. And you ruined it. Blah, blah. It's so funny. Like a great mom in comedy and you ruined it, blah, blah.
我不干了。”然后更有意思的是，他们开始在MySpace上给我发私信。可见那是多久以前的事了。克利夫兰的人发私信说：“老兄，本来可以成为喜剧界的一段佳话的，结果被你给毁了。巴拉巴拉。”太搞笑了。就像“本来可以成为喜剧界的一大佳话，结果被你毁了，巴拉巴拉”。
It's so funny, like a lot of listeners of the Opie and Anthony show, the fans, thought they were really educated on stand-up comedy to the point that they would lecture stand-up comedians about it, which is fucking hilarious. I mean, I've watched some plumbering videos, but I don't think I would ever sit there talking to a plumber going like, hey, you know,
太搞笑了，许多《奥皮与安东尼秀》的听众、也就是那些粉丝，觉得自己对单口喜剧非常有研究，甚至到了要对喜剧演员指指点点的地步，这他妈简直太滑稽了。我是说，我看过一些管道修理的视频，但我绝不会坐在那儿对一个水管工指手画脚地说：“嘿，你知道吗，
I think I'm going to use a different size C clamp there. So yeah, that's what I was worried about. So my next gig I had after that was the punch line. And I went from 10,000 people on the tour to just doing this perfect size comedy club that was only like 180 people. And I was like terrified in the green room. Like that's how my brain used to think.
我觉得我在那儿得用一个不同尺寸的C形夹。”所以，对，这就是我当时担心的。因此我之后的下一场演出是在Punch Line喜剧俱乐部。我从巡演时面对的一万名观众，一下子变成了只在一个只有180人左右、尺寸完美的喜剧俱乐部里表演。我在后台休息室里怕得要命。我以前的大脑就是这么运作的。
I used to, you know, catastrophize. I don't do it anymore, but I used to be. And then this is going to happen, this happened. I don't do it anymore, but I used to be, and then this is going to happen, this happened, and I'm going to live at home with my parents, and I'm going to watch them die. I would literally do that over a bad set. So I went up on stage at the punchline,
我总是，你知道的，把事情灾难化。我现在不这样了，但我以前就是那样。然后心里就会想：接下来这事会发生，那事会发生，然后我要搬回家跟父母一起住，眼睁睁看着他们死去。我甚至会为了一场糟糕的演出在脑子里把这套流程走一遍。所以当时我走上了Punch Line的舞台，
and it was like, these were fans of my act. The Opie and Anthony show wasn't in San Francisco. And then also the big thing is I could see all of them. It takes no balls to boo somebody when you're in row 40 on up. I can't see you, you know what I mean? So I could really get them. We'll be right back.
台下全都是我节目的粉丝。旧金山没有《奥皮与安东尼秀》。而且最棒的是，我能看清台下的每一个人。当你站在第40排往后的地方去嘘别人时，是一点压力都没有的。我又看不见你，你知道我的意思吧？所以我真的能拿他们开涮。我们马上回来。
All right, back to the show. Has there ever been a heckler that's been really good? Oh yeah. Like funny, yeah. Or just bizarre. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I would say like the angrier people, because then it's this weird thing where you have to get them
好的，欢迎回到节目。有没有哪个起哄者是真的很厉害的？哦，有啊。就比如真的很搞笑，或者纯粹很奇葩。对，对，对。我会说是那些脾气更暴躁的人，因为接下来就会变成一种诡异的状况，你必须搞定他们
to maintain the audience's respect, but if you get them too well, are they coming up here now? Yeah, yeah, right, right. Oh, I had a woman throw a shoe at me one time. I was doing a gig in Spanish Harlem for this comic Smokey, who's absolutely hilarious. Remember he had this hilarious bit about a crackhead trying to steal a parrot out of a pet store,
来维持观众对你的尊重，但如果你把他们拿捏得太过了，他们现在是要冲上台来吗？对，对，没错，没错。哦，有一次有个女人朝我扔鞋子。当时我在西班牙哈莱姆区给一个叫斯莫吉的喜剧演员的演出暖场，他绝对是个天才。记得他以前有个超搞笑的段子，讲的是一个瘾君子试图从宠物店里偷一只鹦鹉，
and he would have the mic under his shirt yelling, I came in with it, I came in with it. He was fucking hilarious, right? So, it was like this weird sort of like, you know, it was like a satellite room. So it wasn't a comedy club. It was almost like, you know, like when those lecture halls with the teachers way down and they go up like that? Yeah. So I was doing the gig, right? And I'm doing the thing and I was like,
他把麦克风塞在衬衫底下大喊：“我是带着它进来的，我是带着它进来的！”他他妈太搞笑了，对吧？所以，那是一个很诡异的场所，你知道的，有点像个阶梯教室。所以那不是个喜剧俱乐部。几乎就像是，你知道的，那种讲座大厅，讲台在最下面，座位一层层往上递增的那种？对。所以我在那里演出，对吧？我正演着呢，然后我当时
sort of like leaning forward as I was doing this and the shoe came down, because I got into it with this woman and it hit me like right on my inner thigh. And I immediately was going to get mad, you know? Somebody throws something at me on stage, but then there was this tension because was it all black crowd?
一边表演一边身体向前微倾，然后那只鞋子就飞了下来，因为我刚才跟这个女人杠上了，鞋子正好砸在我大腿内侧。我当时本能地就要生气了，你知道吗？有人在台上朝我扔东西，但现场随后陷入了一种紧张的氛围，因为台下几乎全是黑人观众？
I'm a white dude, like what's going to happen? And I was able to turn it around because I looked, you know, I picked up this shoe and the shoe was, oh my God, it looked like it got dragged down the street by a bus, right? So it was like, like really quiet in the place. I was like, you know, I was going to get mad, but then I looked at this shoe
而我是个白人小伙，这会发生什么？但我成功扭转了局面，因为我看了看，你知道的，我捡起了那只鞋，那只鞋——哦天哪——看起来就像是被公共汽车在街上拖行过一样，对吧？所以现场变得特别安静。我本来，你知道的，我本来要生气的，但当我看了看这只鞋，
and then they all started laughing. And I was like, and I realized this isn't about me. This is about a childhood of no hugs. I forget what it was. And all I remember was I got everyone to laugh again and then she came down to the stage to get her shoe. Wow. Jesus.
然后全场开始大笑。我就想——我意识到这其实不是针对我。这纯粹是因为童年缺少拥抱导致的。我忘了当时具体怎么说的了。我只记得我重新把所有人逗笑了，然后她居然走到台前来拿她的鞋。哇。天哪。
So I was like, what are we doing? We gonna like hug this out? We gonna hug it out? And she was cool. She came up, we gave a big hug. I gave her a shoe back. Wow. And it was so cool, like a few weeks later,
所以我当时就想：我们在干嘛？我们要来个世纪大和解吗？我们要抱一下吗？她挺随和的。她走上台来，我们狠狠地拥抱了一下。我把鞋还给了她。哇。太酷了，几个星期后，
I was riding the Downtown Six, I was living on the Upper East Side at the time, and I ran into this woman that was at the show, and she was just like, how was it your show when that woman threw the shoe, and she goes, me and my friends are still talking about that, blah, blah, blah, blah, you know, like once again, no one knew who I was.
我正坐着市中心6号线地铁——我当时住在上东区——然后我遇到了一个也去看了那场演出的女人，她直接说：“那个女人扔鞋的时候，你的演出太绝了，”她说她和她的朋友们现在还在聊那件事，巴拉巴拉巴拉，你知道的，就像我说的，没人认识我。
Yeah, yeah. So those little like moments of validation of like, oh my God, like, blah. Once again, no one knew who I was. So those little moments of validation of like, oh my God, they went to my show, not only did they like it, they're talking about it. They remember you. Well yeah, those are those little things along the way as you keep getting kicked in the chest that keep you going.
对，对。所以那些微小的被认可的时刻，比如“哦天哪，巴拉巴拉”。再次重申，没人认识我。所以那些微小的被认可的时刻，比如“哦天哪，他们去看了我的演出，不仅喜欢，还在讨论它。他们还记得我”。好吧，对，这些就是你在不断遭受生活暴击的旅途中，能够支撑你继续前行的微小动力。
Bill, I wanted to ask just about something that you mentioned earlier reminded me, because I've seen you talk about it before and I remember talking about somebody asking you if you were nervous about, fuck, I forget what it was, whether it was like Conan or- Yes is the answer, whatever it is. If you were nervous about, no was the answer,
比尔，我刚才想问你一件事，你刚才提到的话题勾起了我的回忆，因为我以前看过你谈论这个，我记得有人问你是否对——操，我忘了具体是什么了，是柯南还是——答案是“是”，不管是什么。你是否对——不，答案是“不”，
about what people, no, it was Bill Maher asking what your reaction was to people online and their comments about shit that you said. And I loved what you said at the time, which was like, I don't give a fuck what 100 people on Twitter say, a bunch of fucking losers. And you kind of went off on a bit of a thing about it. Oh yeah, that is true, yes.
关于人们对——不，是比尔·马尔问你对网民在网上对你言论的评论有什么反应。我当时特别喜欢你的回答，你说的是：“我他妈才不在乎推特上那100个人怎么说，一帮失败者罢了。”然后你顺着这个话题狠狠吐槽了一番。哦对，确实是这样，没错。
Right? And talk a little bit about that, because I remember you, because earlier you were saying it was early on in probably in social media when you did the show in the Opie and Andy show in Philadelphia. And then you were worried about what it was going to do online and go viral blah blah blah. Now you don't give a shit about what people say. Is that true? It's kind of what I'm getting at.
对吧？能稍微聊聊这个吗，因为我记得你刚才说过，你在费城那个《奥皮与安东尼秀》演出时，正值社交媒体刚兴起的早期。然后你当时很担心这事会在网上发酵、病毒式传播之类的。现在你根本不在乎别人怎么说了。是这样吗？这就是我想表达的。
Yeah, I just kind of learned, you know, there was that weird period in standup where it started with the Me Too movement, which was amazing that it went from like, let's get rapists and sexual assaulters out of the business. And within like 18 months, it became like, hey, I don't like what you're talking about in your standup act. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
对，我只是慢慢学会了，你知道的，单口喜剧界曾有过一段诡异的时期，从“我也是”运动开始，一开始的初衷棒极了，比如把强奸犯和性侵犯清除出这个行业。但在大概18个月内，它就变成了一种风气：“嘿，我不喜欢你在单口喜剧里谈论的话题。对，对，对。”
Your career's over. It just got spun out of control. Like, so, and then that's when people started, I would be doing interviews and they were saying, you know, some of the statements you made last night on stage, it's like, there was no statements. There was no jokes. Right, right, right.
“你的职业生涯完蛋了。”事情彻底失控了。所以，从那以后人们开始——我以前去接受采访时，他们会说：“你知道你昨晚在台上发表的一些言论……”我就想，我根本没发表什么言论。那只是个笑话。对，对，对。
Yeah, and what I would just always say is like, listen, you know, I'm up there joking around, all right? If you make the decision to take what I said seriously, doesn't mean that I now meant it. Right, right, right. You know what I mean? So you're free to do that if that's what you want to do. You're not gonna have a good time. Right. You know what I mean? Like I was in some place recently and there was a giant river next to the theater just rushing down the thing. I was like, you know, this is a great city to kill your wife. Throw it in and it goes down, you know, they have no idea where she is.
是的，我总是会说，听着，我在台上只是开玩笑，好吗？如果你决定把我的话当真，并不代表我本来就是那个意思。对，对，对。你知道我的意思吗？所以如果你想这么做，你是自由的。不过你可不会有什么好果子吃。对。你知道我的意思吗？就像我最近去了一个地方，剧院旁边有一条巨大的河，水流湍急地奔流而下。当时我就想，你知道，这是一个谋杀妻子绝佳的城市。把她扔下去，尸体顺流而下，你知道的，他们根本不知道她在哪里。
Just a stupid thing like that, right? Now if you go like, and then there's going to be somebody and they go, you know, my best friend got killed by his husband. It's like, yeah, well I didn't do it, you know, in every city. I'm not saying to do it, I'm being ridiculous. I said that, I have to explain comedy to you. Like why would you, why would you come here? Do we think that that's over now?
就是这种蠢话，对吧？现在，如果你说，然后就会有人跳出来说，你知道，我最好的朋友被她丈夫给谋杀了。这就好比，是啊，我又没干这事，你知道的，每个城市都有这种事。我不是叫你去杀人，我只是在开玩笑。我都说到这份上了，还得跟你解释喜剧是怎么回事。话说你为什么，你为什么会来这儿？我们以为这事儿已经过去了对吧？
Like yeah, Shaunie, right? I mean, I guess. It never happened. It never happened. It was in New York and LA, but then as a comedian you went out on the road, but the problem is all of these people that were like sort of controlling that narrative
比如，对吧，肖妮？我是说，我猜吧。这事从来没发生过。从没发生过。这事儿在纽约和洛杉矶发生过，但后来作为喜剧演员，你得去各地巡演，问题是所有这些掌握着那种话语权的人
sort of sit here in New York or LA. And then that's. With their hands on the buttons. Well, that's their universe, yeah. That's why like, my favorite thing in the world is watching these idiots on award shows lecturing people about race, right? You know, they go up there and they gotta say something about that and homophobia, blah, blah, blah,
基本上都坐在纽约或洛杉矶。然后就是这样。他们掌握着生杀大权。嗯，那是他们的世界，对吧。所以这也就是为什么，我这辈子最喜欢的事，就是看颁奖典礼上的这帮白痴对人们说教种族问题，对吧？你知道的，他们上台去，就得对那个以及恐同之类的破事发表一番高论，
whatever the fuck they're doing. And you look at Hollywood, they're just now integrating. Like sports integrated like almost 80 fucking years ago. And then now they're just getting around to giving more people opportunities. And it's like, dude, what the fuck, what fucking world are you going to sit here in lecture? Because what, oh, Black Lives Matter,
随便他们整的什么破事。你看看好莱坞，他们现在才刚开始搞多元融合。而体育界差不多在80年前就已经融合了。然后到现在，他们才开始着手给更多人提供机会。这就好比，老兄，搞什么鬼，你到底活在什么破世界里，还好意思坐在这儿说教？就因为，哦，黑人的命也是命，
you had your Instagram page all black for one day. Wow. Way to go, yeah. I Instagram page all black for one day, wow. Way to go, yeah. I had to be on the right side of history. That's what I love about my people, and I always say my people, I hate when, and I was guilty that when white people say white people, it's like, no, it's us.
你的Instagram主页黑了一整天。哇。真有你的，是啊。Instagram主页黑了一整天，哇。真有你的，是啊。我得站在历史正确的一边。这就是我喜欢我们这群人的地方，我总是说我们这群人，我讨厌当，我以前也干过这种事，当白宫人说白宫人的时候，不对，是我们。
I hate when we fucking do shit like that, and we think like that stupid gesture is still about us. I had to, you guys, I just had to use my voice to fucking, it's like you didn't even leave your fucking apartment. Right, I know. I know. We didn't even get into like the,
我讨厌我们特么搞这种事情，还以为那种愚蠢的姿态跟我们有什么关系。我不得不，你们这些家伙，我只是不得不发出我特么的声音，这就好像你连特么的公寓都没出过一样。对，我知道。我知道。我们甚至都还没开始聊那个，
like I don't like, I'm like Will and Jason, I'm a big fan and I've, you know, wanted you on the show for a couple years now because I just, I laugh every time I see you and, But I don't know anything. Were you supposed to be on the show once a couple years now, because I laugh every time I see you. And I don't know anything. Were you supposed to be on the show once and it didn't work out? We had a time.
就像我不太喜欢，我跟威尔和杰森一样，我是个超级粉丝，而且我，你知道的，几年前就想请你上节目了，因为我每次看到你都会笑，但我什么都不知道。你是不是几年前就应该上一次节目，因为我每次看到你都会笑。我什么都不知道。你是不是以前就该上一次节目，结果没去成？我们当时约好了时间。
I know we've been trying for a while. I had a meltdown, I couldn't figure it out. So now I have a guy that helps me out. Okay, all right. That's good. So you were born in Massachusetts, your parents were doctors, right? Your dad or your mom was a dentist?
我知道我们一直在尝试。我当时情绪崩溃了，状态一团糟。所以现在我找了个帮手。好吧，好吧。那挺好。所以你出生在马萨诸塞州，你父母都是医生，对吧？你爸爸还是你妈妈是牙医？
No, my dad was a dentist, but he's a narcissist, so he thought he was a doctor. Okay. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I know. He also thought I had a stomach ache and it was a ruptured appendix, but that's a different story. What did mom do? She's a nurse.
不，我爸是牙医，但他是个自恋狂，所以他以为自己是医生。好吧。对，对，对。我懂。他还以为我只是肚子痛，结果其实是阑尾炎穿孔，不过那是另一回事了。你妈妈是做什么的？她是个护士。
Okay. My mom's a beast. My mom's a beast. CCRN, ICU, She had all the letters. And I remember one of the funniest things ever, as far as like a job becomes a job. I was dropping her off at work. We pull in, she just goes,
好吧。我妈是个狠角色。我妈是个狠角色。重症监护注册护士，ICU，她身上有一大堆头衔。我记得最搞笑的一件事是，当工作变成了单纯的工作。当时我正开车送她去上班。我们把车开进去，她突然来了一句：
ah Christ, will you look at all those ambulances? And I just bursted out laughing. She goes, I know, I know. I shouldn't look at it that way. But she was like, yeah, she's, she has, she's, I've seen her save a couple people's lives, like when they had issues. I love that. I love that. In public, she just like I've seen her save a couple people's lives like when they had issues. I love that, I love that.
噢天哪，你看看那些救护车！我当时一下子就笑喷了。她说，我知道，我知道。我不该这么想。但她就是这样，她，她有，我见过她救了好几个人的命，比如他们突发急症的时候。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。在公共场合，她就好像——我见过她救了好几个人的命，比如他们突发急症的时候。我太喜欢了，我太喜欢了。
In public, she just like knows what to do. Yeah, someone was having a stroke and she immediately looked at her watch and all of that stuff and knew that they had this enzyme. Thank God now that they can shoot in and if they do it within some amount of time. Within the first hour. What do you mean, what do you mean?
在公共场合，她就是知道该做什么。对，当时有人中风了，她立刻看了一眼手表之类的，知道他们有一种特效酶。谢天谢地，现在他们可以注射这种酶，只要在一定时间内完成的话。在头一个小时内。你什么意思，什么意思？
My, I had a family member who just had it six months ago and he got it 58 minutes after having his first symptoms. Of what? Of having a stroke and the doctor said, you're fucking lucky that you got it. What's the symptoms? Well, this person, their eye was like tearing up. That's what made my mother clock it.
我，我有个家属在六个月前刚经历过这个，他在出现第一次症状58分钟后就用上了。什么症状？嗯，这人的眼睛一直在流泪。这就是让我母亲注意到原因。
The eye tears up. The eye was tearing up. The person was in like a CVS or something. They were trying to get some ointment for like their eye because it was like tearing up. We happened to be there. So my mother was just like silently like clocked like a fucking like a secret service.
眼睛在流泪。眼睛在流泪。那个人当时在一家CVS便利店还是什么地方。他们想买点眼药水之类的，因为眼睛一直在流泪。我们恰好也在那儿。所以，我母亲就像特勤局特工一样，默默地注意到了这一切。
Like she was just read like, okay, you know, she just knows that that could be a thing or whatever. And then the person couldn't talk and they just went down. It was fucking scary. Wow. And so, and everyone was like freaking out talk and they just went down, it was fucking scary. And everyone was like freaking out and she was just like cool as a cucumber. Called the ambulance, they got there,
就像她一眼就能看出，好吧，你知道的，她只是知道这可能是某种征兆之类的。然后那个人就说不出话来，直接倒下了。当时可特么吓人了。哇。然后，所有人都吓坏了，说不出话来，直接倒下了，那可真特么吓人。所有人都惊慌失措，而她却镇定自若。打了急救电话，救护车赶到了，
and when they showed up, I couldn't, I'd just seen her in action, she like knew what time it started, you know, so they knew and then they shot the enzyme in and they were able to break up the clot. That's pretty cool. Well, so these are both serious people, Mom and Dad. How'd they feel about you taking the right turn
等他们到的时候，我简直不敢相信，我刚亲眼见证了她的雷厉风行，她记住了发病的时间，你知道的，所以他们心里有数，然后注射了特效酶，成功疏通了血栓。这太酷了。好吧，所以这两个都是狠角色，你爸妈。他们对你转行去
into comedy? No, they would totally support it. But they're also like artists. Like my dad is a, you know, plays a bunch of different instruments, can draw you as you're sitting. There's amazing at drawing and all of that stuff. And then my mother is a stealth artist because she grew up in the 40s and was left-handed
说脱口秀有什么看法？不，他们完全支持。但他们本身也挺像艺术家。比如我爸是个，你知道的，会玩各种乐器，还能边看你坐着边给你画像。他的画画功底好得惊人，诸如此类的。然后我母亲是个隐藏的艺术家，因为她生长在40年代，而且是个左撇子，
and that meant you were the devil. So they made her right-handed and she's actually a left-handed person. And it sort of became a theme, I think, in my mother's life of like, I wanted this, but they made me do that. And she just, oh, okay, I guess that's what you do. So she's had like this sort of funny experience with that.
这意味着你就是魔鬼化身。所以他们硬把她掰成了右撇子，但她实际上是个左撇子。我觉得这某种程度上成了我母亲人生中的一个主题，那就是：我想要这个，但他们逼我做那个。而她当时就只是，哦，好吧，我想这就是你该做的。所以她对这事有着某种类似这种滑稽的经历。
And then later in life, she's tapped into that side of her, the artistic side. But like- That's great. I like that, that's really cool. So they always encouraged you in the arts and shit when you were growing up? Yeah, yeah, I mean, they didn't have any problem
后来到了晚年，她才重新发掘了自己身上的那一面，也就是艺术的那一面。但是——太棒了。我喜欢这个，这真的很酷。所以你从小到大，他们一直都很鼓励你搞艺术那些破事吗？对，对，我是说，他们对
with me going into it. But my mother is like, you know, she's like German Midwestern, so like it took the longest time to get like a compliment. Like it was just like, I like almost like stopped telling her when I was on TV. And then I remember one time I went back to Boston, I did this show at the Comedy Connection
我走这条路没有任何意见。但我妈这人吧，你知道的，她是那种中西部的德国后裔，所以要让她夸你一句简直比登天还难。那感觉就好像，我上电视的时候都快懒得告诉她了。后来我记得有一次我回波士顿，在喜剧连接（Comedy Connection）演出，
when it was in Fanule Hall and I just went on, I caught his own and I just murdered, the whole time I was up there. And I got off stage and I remember she just went, now that was a good show. And I said, all right, I finally got her. And then for like the next six years, every show I did, she compared to the Boston one.
当时它还在法尼尔厅（Faneuil Hall），我一上台就进入了状态，简直全场炸裂，我在台上的那一整场表现无懈可击。我一下台，我记得她就说了句：嗯，那场演出确实不错。我说，好吧，我终于搞定她了。然后接下来的六年里，我演的每一场演出，她都要拿来跟波士顿那场作对比。
That was good, it wasn't like that set you did in Boston. I was like, Mom, why do you do this? She goes, I'm trying to make it better. I'm just trying. And then what were some of the first couple of gigs you had, did you work at a warehouse or something when you first started, like before you started doing standup or something right out of college?
那场挺好，但可不如你在波士顿的那场。当时我就想，妈，你干嘛要这样？她说，我这是想让你变得更好。我只是在努力。然后你刚开始做的那几场演出是什么样的？你刚开始起步，或者说在你开始做单口喜剧之前，刚大学毕业那会儿，是在仓库打过工什么的吗？
What were you surprised? Yeah, I did a lot of warehousing. I tried like landscaping stuff, but just being a redhead in the sun, it was just brutal. I tried roofing and stuff. It was just, I was going to die, I'd be dead at skin cancer by the time I was 20.
你很惊讶吗？对，我在仓库干过很多活。我试过园林绿化之类的工作，但作为一个顶着太阳的红头发白人，那简直是惨绝人寰。我还试过铺屋顶之类的。那简直要命，我到20岁时就会死于皮肤癌了。
But how, you don't strike me as a sort of a flippant or reckless person, so how confident were you that comedy was gonna be a career for you and did you sort of, you know, protect yourself a bit by studying other things or like, was there a plan B? Ah, dude, I sucked at everything. Like, I just, I had massive, massive fucking ADD. Massive childhood trauma and shit,
但是怎么说呢，你看上去不像那种轻浮或鲁莽的人，所以你当时对喜剧能成为你的职业有多大信心？你有没有通过学习其他东西来稍微保护一下自己，比如，有没有B计划？啊，老兄，我干啥啥不行。真的，我有严重得不行的注意力缺陷多动症（ADD）。严重的童年创伤之类的，
and like, I was like, yeah, like fucking, I get like, I think I first started getting alopecia when I was like 12, just from like fucking stressing, just being in a fight or flight. I want to talk about that. For shit, I'm not going to get into. Like people always try to get those stories out of me. I'm like dude, you know what, like 17 people
而且，我当时就，是的，我开始，我想我大概12岁左右就开始出现斑秃了，纯粹是被压力逼的，整天处于战斗或逃跑的状态。我想聊聊这个。有些破事，我是不会拿出来说的。人们总想从我这儿套出那些故事。我只想说，老兄，你知道吗，大概得有17个人
would have to be dead before I could tell those fucking stories of not a fight. Innocent people. So. But there was no, you say you suck at everything. I don't believe you. I bet if you wanted to point yourself in a direction, whether it be, well maybe even medicine. I mean look, you. I bet if you wanted to point yourself in a direction,
死翘翘了，我才能讲那些破事，而且还得不是在战斗中。无辜的人。所以。但没有，你说你干啥啥不行。我不信。我敢打赌，如果你想把精力集中在一个方向上，无论是，嗯，也许甚至是医学。我是说，你看你。我敢打赌，如果你想把精力集中在一个方向上，
whether it be, well, maybe even medicine. I mean, look at your two parents. So were there brothers or sisters that were carving a path? I could show you some report cards that would debunk that theory. No, I was like a fucking cat on a leash, dude. Like, I don't know what it was.
不管是，嗯，甚至可能是医学。我是说，看看你的父母。那么有没有哪个兄弟姐妹开辟了别的道路？我能给你看几张成绩单，直接就能把那个理论给粉碎了。不，我当时就像一条拴着绳子的猫，老兄。真的，我不知道是怎么回事。
Like everything, I just wanted to, every place I was, I didn't know what it was, like everything. I was, I just wanted to, every place I was, I didn't fit in, I just was always outside the thing, looking at it, and I was looking at everybody else, and I was trying to do what they were doing. It was like my, like, it was really an outer body experience most of my childhood. And then I, when I went down to my second show I ever did, it was this long gone comedy club, Stitch's Comedy Club.
就像任何事，我只想，我待的每一个地方，我都不知道怎么回事，就像任何事。我当时，我只想，我待的每一个地方，我都格格不入，我总是游离在圈子之外，冷眼旁观，看着其他人，然后试图模仿他们的行为。在我童年的大部分时间里，那真的就像是一种灵魂出窍的体验。然后，当我去看我这辈子第二场演出时，那是一家早已关门大吉的喜剧俱乐部，叫斯特奇喜剧俱乐部（Stitch's Comedy Club）。
And I remember walking in there and there was all of these fucking damaged open micers and it was the first time I ever felt like I was around the same kind of weird that I was. I had found the right nuts to hang out with and like how they viewed the world and how they interacted with it made sense. And who were some of those guys,
我记得走进去的时候，里面全是一帮饱受摧残的开放麦演员，那是我有生以来第一次觉得，我终于和跟我一样怪异的一群人待在了一起。我找到了志同道合的怪咖朋友，他们看待世界的方式以及与世界互动的方式让我觉得很有共鸣。当时都有谁，
who were some of the guys that we would know that you kind of came up with? Because I'm always fascinated by people who are now famous, who hung out with other people who are now famous before you made it. Oh, I had a killer group. It was, I came up, let's see, Dane Cook, Patrice O'Neill, Robert Kelly,
有哪些我们认识的人是跟你同期出道的？因为我对那些现在成名的人非常着迷，他们在成功之前就跟其他现在也成名的人混在一起。哦，我有一群王牌队友。当时，和我同期的有，让我想想，丹·库克（Dane Cook）、帕特里斯·奥尼尔（Patrice O'Neill）、罗伯特·凯利（Robert Kelly），
and then there was this kid who came down from Maine, Bob Marley. That was his real name. He was born in like 67. So that was before Bob Marley made it. That's funny. And everyone was telling us... That was the last year the Leafs won. Yeah, oh yeah, that's right. You haven't won since Bob Marley wasn't famous.
然后还有一个从缅因州来的小伙子，鲍勃·马利（Bob Marley）。那是他的真名。他大概是67年出生的。所以那是在那个“鲍勃·马利”成名之前。这太搞笑了。每个人都在告诉我们……那是枫叶队最后一次捧杯。对，哦，对，没错。自从鲍勃·马利不出名以后，你们就再也没赢过。
He was growing his first dreadlock. I can't believe you're fucking... Bring everything back. You had to mention 60 fucking 7. It's unbelievable. I love you guys, and I don't understand why you hate the Bruins. We have a mutual... You got a lot of good Canadians who won that cup for you. Hang on. Let me ask you, Bill.
他当时正在长出他的第一根脏辫。我真不敢相信你特么的……什么都要扯到这上面来。你非得提特么的67年。这简直不可思议。我爱你们这群人，但我就是不明白你们为什么那么恨棕熊队。我们有着共同的……你们有很多优秀的加拿大人帮你们赢得了那个冠军杯。等一下。让我问你个问题，比尔。
You talk about your second show. How'd you end up doing your first stand-up? I think it was a lot of Europeans who won that cup for us. You're just assuming that you guys still dominate the league. How'd you end up doing your first stand-up? Yeah, yeah. I think there was a lot of Europeans won that cup for us. You're just assuming that you guys still dominate the league. Well, you had fucking Brad Marsh on it, and you also had Bergeron was your captain. Well, there's two guys.
你刚才提到你的第二场演出。你是怎么开始尝试第一场单口喜剧的？我想当时有很多欧洲人帮我们赢得了那个冠军杯。你只是自以为你们仍然统治着整个联盟。你是怎么开始尝试第一场单口喜剧的？对，对，对。我想当时有很多欧洲人帮我们赢得了那个冠军杯。你只是自以为你们仍然统治着整个联盟。好吧，你们当时有特么的布拉德·马尚（Brad Marchand），你们的队长还是伯杰龙（Bergeron）。好吧，那是两个人。
No, I guess Charo was your captain at the time. Anyway. Oh, that's what the problem is. You guys don't realize you need a team. No. Hey, listen. Listen. Is that why you're never balanced, and you buy like three fucking zillion-dollar forwards, and you have no fucking defense? Not true. We drafted all those guys. Anyway, except for Tsevaris. Listen, Bill, how did you end up at your first show?
不，我猜当时查拉（Chara）是你们的队长。总之。哦，问题就出在这儿。你们这些家伙根本没意识到你们需要一个团队。不。嘿，听着。听着。这就是为什么你们从来都不均衡，总是买三个特么的身价过亿的前锋，却特么一点防守都没有？才没有。那些人都是我们选秀选来的。总之，除了塔瓦雷斯（Tavares）之外。听着，比尔，你怎么会去参加第一场演出？
How was it that you went, I'm going up tonight to do stand up tonight? I was so walled off and shy that I had to make a New Year's resolution in 1992. I said, at some point this year, I had to get myself a whole fucking year. But were you writing jokes before you were like, no. No, but prepare? Then I would have to think about what I had to do.
你怎么就突然决定，我今晚要上台去讲单口喜剧？我以前性格极其孤僻内向，以至于我在1992年许下了新年愿望。我说，今年无论如何，我必须给自己一整年的时间去折腾。但你上台前写过段子吗？没有。没有，但做过准备吗？那我肯定得琢磨琢磨我该干点啥。
I'd be like, I need to write jokes. Oh, look at this can. Oh, let me fucking do something with this. I'd be like, I need to write jokes. Oh, look at this can. Oh, let me fucking do something with this. Um, I, uh, no, and like once I, I made that thing in my head and I was going to Emerson College at that time.
我会想：我得写段子。哦，你看这个罐子。哦，让我特么拿这玩意儿整点活。我会想：我得写段子。哦，你看这个罐子。哦，让我特么拿这玩意儿整点活。嗯，我，呃，没有，而且一旦我，我在脑子里下了这个决心，我当时正在爱默生学院（Emerson College）读书。
And the whole reason I was going to Emerson College, two reasons, one, I had to get a college degree because my parents were professionals and they wanted me to do that. So I was doing that. And then two, it was a performance school. So I went there to get over stage fright. I had real no, like I majored in mass communications.
我上爱默生学院的全部原因，主要有两个：第一，我得拿个大学学位，因为我父母都是专业人士，他们希望我这么做。所以我当时在按部就班地做。第二，这是一所表演学校。所以我去那里是为了克服怯场。我其实根本没有什么，比如我的专业是大众传播学。
I didn't, I just majored, I was majoring in volunteering to get in front of fucking people. I did radio so I could be on a microphone and talk to people, but I didn't have to see him. It was very baby steps. So I made this New Year's resolution and then there was a school paper.
我没想过，我只是把专业当成了志愿站在特么所有人面前的借口。我搞广播是为了能对着麦克风跟人说话，但又不用直视他们。这绝对是婴儿学步式的迈步。所以我许下了这个新年愿望，然后学校里有一份校报，
I don't know if they still have it there, the Emersonian, and there was an ad in the paper. It was this contest at Nick's Comedy Stop. Find Boston's Funniest College Student, which was just a big sales promotion to get a bunch of drunk kids, college kids in there buying beer, watching their friends bomb. So I signed up, I went home and signed up.
我不知道他们现在还在不在那里办，叫《爱默生人报》（The Emersonian），报纸上登了一个广告。那是尼克斯喜剧站（Nick's Comedy Stop）举办的一场比赛。寻找波士顿最搞笑的大学生，这其实只是一场大型促销活动，目的是把一帮喝醉了的大学的孩子们吸引到那儿去买啤酒，看着他们的朋友在台上砸场子。所以我报名了，我回家后就报了名。
It was funny, my parents are into antiques, so they had this resto mod phone. I was literally like, yeah, hello operator. I'd like to get in a showbiz. You opened it up, it was still a push button phone. And I just called up and I signed up for the contest. And I showed up and I went up and did it. It didn't go well.
说来好笑，我父母对古董很感兴趣，所以他们家里有一个复古改良版的电话。我当时真的就像是在说：喂，接线员。我想进演艺圈。你打开一看，它居然还是个按键电话。然后我就打电话报名参加了比赛。比赛那天我去了，上台表演了。结果并不算太好。
It went okay. What'd you do? What was the first thing, do you remember? I went up and did it. It didn't go well. It went okay. What'd you do? What was the first thing? Do you remember? I'm really curious about this. Like you get up on, you do this fucking thing and then you get up on stage and then what? Well, it really is the funniest thing to get into
还算过得去。你当时表演了什么？你还记得第一个段子是什么吗？我上台表演了。结果并不算太好。还算过得去。你当时表演了什么？第一个段子是什么？你还记得吗？我对这个真的很好奇。就像你站上，你特么干了这事，然后你站上舞台，接下来呢？好吧，这真的是一件最搞笑的入行方式，
because you can't really practice it. You have no idea how to do it. The only way to learn how to do it is to just go up and do it. So I do remember sitting down to write jokes for the first time and just staring at the blank page. Like, I don't even know how to do this. So I just started writing stuff and stories
因为你根本无法排练。你完全不知道该怎么做。唯一的学习方法就是硬着头皮上台去演。所以我确实记得自己第一次坐下来写段子时，就只是死死盯着空白的页面。当时心想：我甚至都不知道这该怎么弄。所以我开始写一些经历、故事，
and talking about myself. It was a very self-deprecating set, talking about being a commuter, having no friends, having no girlfriend, basically discussing all the sadness that leads one to start becoming a performer. Right, right, right, right. So it was a lot of that and, you know,
以及谈论我自己。那是一场非常自嘲的演出，谈论自己是个通勤族、没有朋友、没有女朋友，基本上就是把所有促使一个人开始走上表演道路的悲惨经历来了个大盘点。对，对，对，对。所以里面有很大一部分都是这种内容，而且，你知道的，
I went up there, I forgot what I was going to say, I sort of started in the middle of the shit that I could remember and I kind of meandered. But I remember getting off stage and I do remember going up to the mic in another like auto-body experience, almost like watching myself taking the mic out of the mic stand and I was just like,
我上台后，把自己要说的话忘了个精光，就从我还能记起来的烂摊子中间开始讲，结果东拉西扯了一通。但我记得下台的时候，我又经历了一次灵魂出窍，几乎就像是在看着自己把麦克风从支架上拿下来，当时我心里就在想：
this is what I'm doing, I'm doing this for the rest of my life, this is what I'm supposed to be doing. And the guy who hosted it, Billy Martin, who's now a big shot at the Bill Maher Show, he gave me Rita Choice's number. Still remember her, she was fucking hilarious. And she used to make me call up the club
这就是我要做的事，我要用余生来做这件事，这正是我该做的事。担任主持人的那个家伙叫比利·马丁（Billy Martin），他现在是《比尔·马赫秀》的大人物了，他给了我丽塔·乔伊斯（Rita Choice）的电话号码。我还记得她，她特么太搞笑了。她总是让我打电话给俱乐部，
and I'd be like, hey Rita, it's Bill Burr, I wanna get some spots. She goes, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. That's not how you talk to me. You have to say, Rita, this is open mic'er Bill Burr. And I just, I thought it was the funniest thing ever. Yeah, I loved it. cause like that was to me, and also she was in the comedy world,
然后我会说：嘿，丽塔，我是比尔·伯尔，我想争取几个演出机会。她就会说：不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不。你不能这么跟我说话。你必须说：丽塔，我是开放麦演员比尔·伯尔。我当时就觉得，这简直是我这辈子听过最好笑的事。对，我超喜欢。因为对我来说，而且她也在喜剧圈里，
and I loved that type of affection. Like that was, like I don't like real affection. Like hey man, I just want to say, you really mean a lot to me. Like literally my toes start going like that, and my sneakers like dude, we can't have a real fucking meeting. I get it.
我非常喜欢那种表达亲近的方式。那种感觉就像是，我其实不太习惯那种肉麻的温情。就像：嘿，兄弟，我只想说，你对我真的很重要。那样的话简直让我脚趾抠地，运动鞋都快穿不下了，老兄，我们没法这么正儿八经地开会。我懂的。
We'll be right back. And now back to the show. Hey, real quick, I got an 18 year old daughter that wants to go to Emerson. Was it great? It's fantastic. It's fantastic. One of the great things that they had was they had people
我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目。嘿，说个正事，我有个18岁的女儿想去爱默生学院。那学校好吗？棒极了。棒极了。它最棒的一点在于，那里有很多
that went there and were doing well in show business and they would come back on a regular basis and they would talk to... I do it. You know, I haven't done it enough. I should do it more. But you come back and what's great about it, I remember sitting there looking at these people who they had produced a movie. I forget what the movie was, but it was something that I had seen. And just to see them being like, oh, they were sitting here, and now they're doing that, like this is like possible because, you know how this business is,
从这里毕业并在演艺圈混得风生水起的人，他们会定期回校，跟……我也去过。你知道的，我回去得还不够多。我应该多去几次的。但当你回去的时候，最棒的地方在于，我记得自己坐在那儿，看着这些制作过电影的人。我忘了那是什么电影了，但那确实是我看过的片子。看着他们坐在那儿说，哦，他们以前也坐在这个位置，现在他们正在做那样的事，这就证明这是完全有可能的，因为，你懂这行的规矩，
this isn't like, you know, you start in the mail room, and then you work your way up to that. There's like, it's just like this field, you just start running and you don't know, oh, they're running this way, I run over here, and like you have no idea, like there's no- Squid Game, yeah. Exactly, yeah.
这可不是那种，你知道的，你从收发室干起，然后一步步高升的行业。这个领域就像是，你直接开跑，根本不知道方向在哪，哦，他们往那边跑，我也往那边跑，你完全一无所知，根本没有——《鱿鱼游戏》，对。没错，是的。
Squid Game. People have fallen, totally Squid Game. Exactly. Squid Game. People have fallen. Totally Squid Game. Quitting, becoming substitute teachers. You have no idea. What the fuck am I doing? But then, Bill, what's so impressive is your massive, hugely successful career in standup
《鱿鱼游戏》。有人出局了，完全就是《鱿鱼游戏》。没错。《鱿鱼游戏》。有人出局了。完全就是《鱿鱼游戏》。放弃了，去当了代课老师。你根本不知道。我特么到底在干什么？但是话说回来，比尔，最让人印象深刻的是你在单口喜剧界取得的巨大成功、极其辉煌的职业生涯，
and doing specials and everything. But what a great actor you are. F is for family. Yeah, how are you digging that? King of Staten Island and then Mandalorian, which I was like, oh my God, Bill Burz on Mandalorian, that was so cool. And then you did Old Dads, which you co-wrote.
还做了各种专场。同时你也是个出色的演员。《福气家族》（F is for Family）。对，你对这个挺上头吧？《史坦顿岛之王》（King of Staten Island），还有《曼达洛人》（Mandalorian），当时我看到的时候惊呼：哦天哪，比尔·伯尔居然在《曼达洛人》里，太酷了吧。然后你还拍了《老爸们》（Old Dads），这是你联合编剧的。
Ben Tishler, yeah. Produced, directed and starred. And I wanted to ask you about Old Dads, because I want to ask Jason too, this, when you first start directing, I was reading about you, Bill, about Old Dad, this, when you first start directing, I was reading about you, Bill, about old dads, and when you first start directing, and you have to call action for the very first time
本·蒂施勒（Ben Tishler），是的。兼任制片、导演和主演。我想问你关于《老爸们》的事，我想问杰森同样的问题，当你们第一次开始当导演时——我之前读过关于你的报道，比尔，关于《老爸们》，当你生平第一次作为导演
in your life as a director, it must feel so awkward. Like if I, I gotta say it with conviction, because if I say action weekly, I won't look like a leader. So I have to kind of, you know what I mean? So isn't that weird to call action for the very first time as a director? Yeah, it was.
大喊“开机”（Action）时，那种感觉肯定极其尴尬。就好像如果我——我必须说得斩钉截铁，因为如果我气势软弱地喊“开机”，看起来就不像个领头人了。所以我必须拿出那种气势，你知道我的意思吗？所以，生平第一次以导演身份喊“开机”，是不是觉得怪怪的？对，确实挺怪的。
Because you've seen it and you've been around it. They also said like there was, you know, the first AD was like, do you want me to say action? And then I kind of realized like, oh, is it hacky now for the director to say action? Do I need to have that old big bullhorn and action? So I just deferred that to them, but I do remember, like, I directed Old Dead's not because I wanted to. I never had any desire. Once again, my fucking ADD and everything, like I was just like, I don't want to, you know, let me just do, you know, I don't give
因为你看过别人这么干，也在那个环境里待过。他们当时还说，你知道的，第一副导演问：你要我来喊“开机”吗？然后我突然意识到，哦，现在由导演自己喊“开机”是不是显得很业余、很老套？我是不是得拿个那种老式的大喇叭来喊“开机”？所以我最后还是把这活儿交回给他们了。但我确实记得，我执导《老爸们》并不是因为我想当导演。我从来没有过这种渴望。又来了，我那该死的注意力缺陷多动症（ADD）和各种毛病，当时我就想：我才不想，你知道的，随便让我干点啥，
a fuck, dude. Give me a line read. Whatever I have to do to get through the fucking day. I don't care, right? So I knew I was in trouble directing. And this is how what happened was we were coming out of COVID. So everybody was committed to all of these projects that they didn't do, plus what they were going to do the next year. So no one was available. So then the start talking going, well, Bill, you wrote this movie. I go, no, I didn't. I wrote it with Ben Tischler.
我特么才不在乎呢，老兄。给我个台词提示就行。只要能混过特么这一天，我什么都愿意干。我才不在乎呢，对吧？所以我知道自己执导这部电影会有麻烦。事情是这样的，当时我们正刚熬过疫情封控。所以每个人都答应了各种之前没能开拍的项目，再加上他们接下来一年本来就要拍的片子。结果根本没人有空。于是他们就开始商量着说：嗯，比尔，这部电影是你写的。我说：不，我不是一个人写的。我和本·蒂施勒一起写的。
Yeah, but it's your voice. No, no, no. And they kept trying to, they were backing me into a corner and then they go, well, I mean, it's getting, you know, it's getting late, it's going to go away. And I just said, all right, fine, I'll do it. And I don't remember 2022 after that. And this is when I knew I was in trouble
是啊，但这满篇都是你的风格。不，不，不。他们一直试图，把我逼入绝境，然后他们说：好吧，我是说，时间不早了，这个项目快要黄了。我当时就说：好吧，行吧，我来拍。从那以后，我就不记得2022年发生过什么了。当时我知道自己有大麻烦了，
was I was talking to the set dresser whatever I never know what the names of the jobs are the person that puts all this stuff in the room, right? Yeah, that person Dancing monkey I have different names for the jobs, but they know what I'm talking about So she goes, okay this scene is it's a backyard barbecue scene, are we thinking paper plates? We think, and I was like, yeah, yeah, paper plates. And she goes, what kind of paper plates? And I was like, oh, fuck.
是因为我跟现场布景师——随便吧，我从来记不住这些工作岗位的名字，就是那个负责把所有道具摆满房间的人，对吧？对，那个人。跳舞的猴子。我对这些工作岗位有各种不同的称呼，但他们懂我的意思。所以她问：好吧，这场戏是后院烧烤的场景，我们觉得是用纸盘子吗？我们觉得，然后我说：对，对，纸盘子。她接着问：什么样纸盘子？当时我就懵了：哦，操。
I go, it's to this level, and then I started thinking, oh, there's directors out there that choose a color palette that I'm just weighing over my head. So the reality of Old Dads is Ben Tichler co-directed with me. So he had my back. And Monica Levinson, I had a ton of help. But the thing was with that thing was I knew how to write jokes and Ben knew how to write structure.
我心想：事情居然细致到了这种地步。然后我开始琢磨，哦，原来有的导演会精心挑选一套色彩搭配方案，而我对此完全一窍不通。所以《老爸们》的实际情况是，本·蒂施勒和我联合执导的。所以他一直在背后罩着我。还有莫妮卡·莱文森（Monica Levinson），我得到了超级多的帮助。但关键在于，我知道怎么写段子，而本知道怎么构建结构。
So we had this scene there and it's like, I wasn't trying to be Stanley Kubrick. So I was just trying to make you laugh. So it wasn't like. I've asked every standup comic that does some acting the same question, how do you like the process of, because as a standup, you come first and then you write words to fit you.
所以我们当时有这么一场戏，而且我也没打算当斯坦利·库布里克（Stanley Kubrick）。我只是想逗大家笑而已。所以这并不是什么……我问过每一个演戏的单口喜剧演员同一个问题：你觉得这种表演过程怎么样？因为作为单口喜剧演员，你是核心，然后你写出适合自己的台词。
As an actor, it's the exact opposite process. Do you enjoy that or is it torture to you to like have to fit a bunch of words in a character that pre-exists? No, no, I love it. I also, I like, I'm envious of the collaboration. Uh-huh. You know what I mean?
而作为演员，过程恰好相反。你享受这个过程吗？还是说，要把一堆台词塞进一个既有的角色里，对你来说简直是一种折磨？不，不，我很喜欢。而且，我非常享受这种合作。哦？你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Like Will knows this, he's been out on the ice with me. I'd rather get an assist than the goal, you know? I put it right on the fucking tape. And what does he do? He shoots it over the crossbar, just like every bum on his team. Jesus Christ, bro.
对，对，对，对。就像威尔懂的，他跟我一起在冰球场上混过。我宁愿送出一次助攻，也不愿自己去进球，你知道吗？我直接把球传到他的冰球棍上。结果他呢？他一脚把球射飞越过了横梁，就像他队里的每一个废柴一样。天呐，老兄。
No, I really like... My acting career, which is funny, is what I always say is I've parrot-trooped into some of the best stuff, and only for a couple of episodes. And people have like this idea of me, yeah, that I have this way bigger acting thing than I do. And it's like, I only did a couple episodes
不，我真的很喜欢……我的演艺生涯，说来滑稽，我总是说我是空降到一些最棒的剧组里，而且往往只演区区几集。人们对我有种误解，以为我的演艺生涯比实际上要宏大得多。而事实是，我只演了
of Breaking Bad, a couple episodes of Chappelle, Man in the Lawry, I've like parrot trouped into these. But you do enjoy it? Not as much as a stand up, but yeah. No, no, I absolutely love it. Like I got an acting gig coming up next year, next month in New York, doing Broadway for the first time. I'm doing...
几集《绝命毒师》，几集《查克·秀》（Chappelle's Show），《曼达洛人》，我就是空降到这些神剧里的。但你确实很享受演戏？没有演单口喜剧那么多，但确实挺享受。不，不，我绝对爱死这行了。我明年，下个月在纽约有个演戏的活儿，第一次登上百老汇的舞台。我要演的是……
Glenn Gary, Glenn Ross. Glenn Gary, Glenn Ross. Oh wow. No way. Yeah, with Kieran Culkin and who else? Oh, fuck dude. We just won a Golden Globe, Bob Odenkirk, Michael McKeon. Oh wow, no way. Yeah, with Kieran Culkin and who else? We just won a Golden Globe, Bob Odenkirk, Michael McKeon. So it's kind of better called Saul Breaking Bad there.
《拜金一族》（Glengarry Glen Ross）。《拜金一族》。哦，哇。真的假的？对，和基兰·卡尔金（Kieran Culkin）以及其他人一起？哦，操，老兄。我们刚赢了金球奖，鲍勃·奥登科克（Bob Odenkirk）、迈克尔·麦基恩（Michael McKeon）。哦，哇。真的假的？对，和基兰·卡尔金以及其他人一起？我们刚赢了金球奖，鲍勃·奥登科克、迈克尔·麦基恩。所以里面有点《风骚律师》和《绝命毒师》的阵容在里面。
Got a little bit of a succession in there. I'm going to see that. When does that open? I think March 10th. Okay, you're excited about that? Is that your first play? Yeah, yeah, never did it, so. How long you doing it?
还有点《继承之战》的演员。我一定要去看看。什么时候开演？我想是3月10号。好的，你对此很兴奋吗？这是你的第一部舞台剧？对，对，从没演过，所以。你要演多久？
Do you know how long you're doing it? How long did it, so. How long you doing it? Do you know how long you're doing it? How long and who's directing? How long you doing it? I'm doing it until the end of June, I believe. So March, April, May, June. Oh, that's not good. That's like, yeah, 16 weeks or whatever, but. What about directing?
你知道你要演多久吗？演多久，所以。你要演多久？你知道你要演多久吗？演多久？导演是谁？你要演多久？我大概要演到六月底吧。所以是三月、四月、五月、六月。哦，那可不短。差不多，对吧，16周左右吧，不过。导演呢？
You think you'll ever direct again? I'm slated to direct the next one I just wrote with Ben. Yeah? After in 2022 going, I'm never doing this again. But like, I don't know, like we kind of, it's like, I always joke, I go, we're like the comedian, you know, and I'm not saying we're anywhere near them, but like comedian Cohen brother type of thing. If it says produced by Ben Tischel,
你觉得你以后还会再当导演吗？我计划执导下一部我和本刚刚写好的电影。是吗？在经历了2022年的那场噩梦、发誓再也不当导演之后？但怎么说呢，我们有点像，我经常开玩笑说：我们就像喜剧界的——虽然我不是说我们能跟他们比，但就像科恩兄弟那种类型的感觉。如果上面写着由本·蒂施勒制片，
know that he was directing too. Listen to this guy says he's like a Cohen brother over here. I just went through all of their movies. I just went through all of the movies that I hadn't seen. Aren't they incredible? I mean, these guys are just, I miss them. You know what's a great one? Here's one to watch with your wife, your lady friend,
那就说明其实他也参与了导演。听听这家伙说的，把自己比作科恩兄弟了。我刚刚把他们所有的电影都刷了一遍。我把他们所有我没看过的电影都看了一遍。难道他们不令人惊叹吗？我是说，这群家伙简直太棒了，我会想念他们的。你知道有一部超级棒的电影吗？这部适合跟你老婆、你的女伴、
your life partner, Sean. Thank you. Thank you, Dad. Good for you, Bill. Paris Jatem. Paris Jatem is something that they just produced and it's a series of like 20, 10 minute short films about love in Paris and all different like, you know, people finding love, people getting divorces, tragic, funny.
你的生活伴侣一起看，肖恩。谢谢。谢谢你，爸爸。真有你的，比尔。巴黎，我爱你（Paris, je t'aime）。《巴黎，我爱你》是他们刚刚制片的一部作品，这是一系列大约20部、每部10分钟的短片，讲述了发生在巴黎的爱情故事，有各种不同的人，你知道的，寻找真爱的、闹离婚的，悲剧的、喜剧的。
It was such a surprise. Amazing movie. That's French for Paris, I love you. Okay. Paris Je T'aime. Wow. Thanks, man love you. Okay. Paris, je t'aime. Wow. Thanks. Okay, well.
这太让人惊艳了。了不起的电影。那是法语里的“巴黎，我爱你”。好吧。巴黎，我爱你。哇。谢谢，兄弟，爱你。好吧。《巴黎，我爱你》。哇。谢谢。好吧，那么。
Because you are very kind, Barry. Once ago, one coffee. No, because I'm not French. He knows that. So, the Monday morning podcast, you started in 2007. Yeah. And you're still doing it. What?
因为你太好了，巴里。来一杯咖啡。不，因为我不是法国人。他知道这一点。所以，周一早晨播客（The Monday Morning Podcast），你是从2007年开始做的。对。而且你现在还在做。什么？
Yeah. So wait, is this it. What? Yeah, yeah. So wait, is this is pre-Deck Shepherd? Is post-Mark Maron pre-Deck Shepherd? Yeah, yeah, I don't know. In the podcast pantheon. Sorry for the way that he marks years and just, I don't know if you're the fucking moron. I didn't know we were gonna do a deep dive
对。等等，那是。什么？对，对。所以等等，这个是在戴克·谢泼德（Dax Shepard）之前？还是在马克·马龙（Marc Maron）之后、戴克·谢泼德之前？对，对，我不知道。在播客名人堂里。抱歉他刚才那种标记年份的方式，简直就像个特么的笨蛋。我不知道我们今天还要深入探讨
into the history of podcasting. No, but I mean, we don't have to, but it's like, wow, I mean, you've been doing it before it was a thing. I was doing it when I used to call in a service on a flip phone. Wow. And I used to be, and that was my first podcasts were only like five, six minutes.
播客的发展历史。不，我的意思是，我们倒也不必如此，但这感觉就像是，哇，我的意思是，你在播客还根本不是个东西的时候就开始做了。我以前用翻盖手机打电话进录音系统来做播客。哇。而且我以前，我最早的播客只有五六分钟长。
It was, it started off with, it was on the MySpace page and you would post it. And I was over Bobby Kelly's apartment once again. And we both live in near each other in New York at the time. And he was the one, he goes, dude, you know, dude, it's a way to connect with your fans, dude. He says, you know, he says, do it a lot, right? And I was like, all right.
刚开始的时候，它是发在MySpace页面上的，你把它贴上去。当时我再次在罗伯特·凯利的公寓里。我们当时都在纽约附近住得很近。是他提议的，他说：老兄，你知道吗，这是与你的粉丝建立联系的好方法，老兄。他说，你知道吗，多搞点这玩意儿，对吧？然后我想：好吧。
So then I just started doing them and I liked it. And it's been this amazing exercise for me because I don't have guests really, so I just sort of babble and then answer questions and stuff and it grew to 10 minutes to 20 minutes, the same way you build like a standup act and now I can just by myself sort of talk for an hour. So like when I shoot a special,
于是我就开始做了，而且我挺喜欢。这对我来说是一种极其美妙的锻炼，因为我基本上没有嘉宾，所以我就是瞎扯淡，然后回答粉丝的问题之类的，后来它从10分钟延长到20分钟，就跟我构思单口喜剧专场的过程一样，现在我可以一个人滔滔不绝地讲上一个小时。所以当我录制专场时，
going out and trying to like, come up with a whole new hour is a lot easier for me, I feel, because of doing that, because I'm not, I'm just, I can go into flow mode. Yeah, got it. Do you, sorry, Shondra, was that painful for you? Yeah, yeah, yeah. As you went online.
出门去尝试构思一整个小时的新段子对我来说要容易得多，我觉得这都要归功于做播客的经历，因为我不是在背稿，我只是进入了心流状态。对，明白了。抱歉，肖恩，刚才那段对你来说很煎熬吗？对，对，对。当你上线的时候。
I know. I got it, I'm surprised with your process. Uh, Bill, do you, do you, do you find yourself doing the, doing the podcast and you, you say something or like something happens like a joke comes out of it and then you, you integrate it into your special. Is that what you're saying?
我知道。我明白了，我对你的创作过程感到很惊讶。比尔，你有没有发现，自己在做播客的时候，说着说着或者发生了什么事——比如突然冒出一个段子，然后你把它融入到你的专场里？你是这个意思吗？
I never used to do that, but lately, lately I have been because the rule is basically if I do it on the podcast, I'm not doing it on the show. But if I feel like it's like, you know, I just waded into the water and it's gonna go a lot deeper than that. Yeah. Like, you know, I had like a dad moment with my two kids
我以前从不这么干，但最近，最近我开始这么做了，因为基本的原则是：如果我在播客里讲了这个段子，我就不会在专场里用它。但如果我觉得它就像是，你知道的，我只是试探性地涉足这个话题，而它其实可以挖掘得更深。比如，你知道的，我有一次带着两个孩子度过了一个温馨的父亲时刻，
that was, you know, it just worked out perfectly. How do I do this? Because I don't want to do the bit, but it was basically, my son wasn't listening to my daughter, and then she was mad at him, and she wanted to get him back, and I gave her the green light to do it, and then she did it like a woman. Like, it was diabolical.
那次经历简直完美。我该怎么处理这事呢？因为我不想把这当成段子来演，但事情的经过大致是这样的：我儿子不听我女儿的话，我女儿气坏了，想要报复他，于是我给了她“绿灯”允许她去报复，然后她就像个成年女性一样干了一票。那手段简直狡猾透顶。
It was fucking amazing. I was just like, holy shit. Like, wow, that is a female brain in there because I never would have thought, you know guys are, oh I'm going to punch you in the face. Like they pitch story and they fucking come up with something and they just put maximum. How old are your kids?
简直特么太精彩了。当时我就想：卧槽。真不愧是女性的大脑，因为我绝不会想到这一点——你知道男人们通常会说：“哦，我要一拳揍扁你。”而女孩子们会精心谋划一个故事，她们能想出各种鬼点子，并且全力以赴地去执行。你的孩子几岁了？
Pain and suffering, seven and four. Soon to be eight. Oh, how fun. Oh yeah, my son's hilarious. His new thing is he'd be like when he gets mad at me, he goes, he goes, my son's hilarious. His new thing is he'd be like, when he gets mad at me, he goes, he goes, that's it, dad. He goes, you're going to jail, I'm calling Kojak.
痛苦与折磨的化身，七岁和四岁。马上就八岁了。哦，太有趣了。哦，是的，我儿子太搞笑了。他的新口头禅是，每当他生我的气时，他就说——我儿子太搞笑了。他的新口头禅是，每当他生我的气时，他就说：
Cause he has an old dad and we watch Kojak. And he loves Kojak. And one of my favorite, like, I don't know if you guys had this with kids when you realized how much you're gonna be friends with them for your whole life. I was sitting on the couch and my son was three and we're watching Kojak, right?
“够了，爸爸。你要进监狱了，我要给科贾克（Kojak）打电话。”因为他有个老爹，而且我们一起看《科贾克》。他可迷《科贾克》了。我最喜欢的时刻之一——我不知道你们带孩子的时候有没有这种体会，就是当你意识到你将成为他们一辈子的好朋友时。有一次我坐在沙发上，我儿子当时三岁，我们在看《科贾克》，对吧？
So it's an old school cop show. So basically anybody who isn't white is running down an alley with a knife, you know what I mean? So it's like this 20 year old Puerto Rican actor in like the prime of his life and he's sprinting down this alley and he's getting chased by the character Stavos who's Telly Savalas' real brother.
那是一部老派的警察剧。所以基本上任何不是白人的人都在拿着一把刀在小巷里狂奔，你知道我的意思吗？所以那是一个20岁左右的波多黎各演员，正处在人生的黄金时期，他在小巷里全速冲刺，后面追着一个叫斯塔沃斯（Stavos）的角色，那演员是泰利·萨瓦拉斯（Telly Savalas）的亲弟弟。
And he has a full head of curly hair and he's fat. He looks like a fucking weeble. And he's chasing this shredded Latino kid. So they show the Latino kid flies down the fucking alley like an Olympian and then Stavos and his loafers is running by and my son is just watching Stavos running. Then he just goes, three years old, he just goes. Ha ha.
他满头卷发，身材胖乎乎的。他看起来就像个他妈的不倒翁。他还在追一个身材精瘦的拉丁裔小孩。然后他们看到那个拉丁裔小孩像个奥运选手一样嗖地冲过小巷，接着斯塔沃斯穿着平底便鞋跑了过去，我儿子就看着斯塔沃斯跑。然后他三岁大，就这样说。哈哈。
Ha ha ha ha. And I looked at him and I started laughing. We both just started cracking up and I was like, oh my God, that's it, we're going to smoke cigars? I'm in, I'm in with this dude. That is great. Yeah, so. Well Billy, that's, it's so nice to meet you.
哈哈哈。我看着他，然后开始笑起来。我们俩都笑得前仰后合，我说，哦天哪，就是这样，我们要抽雪茄吗？我加入，我跟这家伙一伙的。太棒了。是啊，所以。好吧，比利，很高兴认识你。
We've taken way too much of your time. I know you got to go, you got a gig tonight, blah, blah, blah. Listen, don't put your schedule on me. I was ready to fucking put my schedule. I always do. But I didn't get to go, you got a gig tonight, blah, blah, blah. Listen, don't put your schedule on me. I was ready to fucking put my schedule up. I always do. But I didn't get to talk about it. Listen, Bill, I know you got a personal chef
我们占用了你太多时间了。我知道你得走了，你今晚有演出，巴拉巴拉巴拉。听着，别把你的时间安排强加给我。我本来准备好他妈的把我的时间安排。我总是这样。但我还没来得及说，你今晚有演出，巴拉巴拉巴拉。听着，别把你的时间安排强加给我。我本来准备好他妈的把我的时间安排拿出来了。我总是这样。但我没能谈到这个。听着，比尔，我知道你有一个私人厨师
who just made you a fucking egg salad sandwich, no bread. Yeah. Exactly. You can smell it from here. Hey, before I go, Sean, when you did that Jerry Lewis, that was one of my favorite things. Oh, thanks, man. I thought you nailed that.
刚给你做了一个他妈的鸡蛋沙拉三明治，不加面包。对。没错。你从这儿就能闻到。嘿，在我走之前，肖恩，当你模仿那个杰瑞·刘易斯时，那是我最喜欢的环节之一。哦，谢谢你，老兄。我觉得你学得真神。
And obviously Ozark was one of my favorite things. Oh, thanks, man. I thought you nailed that. And obviously Ozark was one of my favorite shows. And Will, I got nothing. Here we go, here we go. I knew it, I knew it. No, no, no. I'll tell you what, being a dad, Lego Batman. Bingo. Fucking amazing.
很显然，《黑钱胜地》是我最喜欢的作品之一。哦，谢谢你，老兄。我觉得你学得真神。很显然，《黑钱胜地》是我最喜欢的节目之一。至于威尔，我什么都没有。来了来了，来了来了。我早就知道了，我早就知道了。不，不，不。我告诉你，当个老爸，乐高蝙蝠侠。全中。他妈的太棒了。
Barb. It's fucking amazing. Thank you, thank you, Bill. Fucking amazing. Yeah, thank you. Well, Bill, you're the king. It makes the adults laugh, it makes the kids laugh. No, you guys are going to take your fucking amazing. Thank you. Thank you, Bill. It's fucking amazing. Well, Bill, you're the king. It makes the adults laugh. You were very nice to do.
巴布。太他妈棒了。谢谢你，谢谢你，比尔。太他妈棒了。是的，谢谢。好吧，比尔，你真是个天才。这让成年人发笑，让孩子们发笑。不，你们要接受你他妈的夸奖。谢谢。谢谢你，比尔。太他妈棒了。好吧，比尔，你真是个天才。这让成年人发笑。你人真好。
It makes the kids laugh. No, you guys are going to take your fucking compliments. Well, thank you for doing this. It's very, very nice of you. Thank you, Bill. Thank you guys for having me. We love you, Bill. Despite everything, we love you.
这让孩子们发笑。不，你们要接受这些他妈的夸赞。好吧，谢谢你做这些。你真是太好了。谢谢你，比尔。谢谢你们邀请我。我们爱你，比尔。尽管发生了一切，我们还是爱你。
All right, I'll see you down at the showbiz commissary at some point, all right? Yeah, exactly. Yeah. All right, guys. Nice to meet you, Bill. All right, nice to meet you guys, too. See you, buddy. All right, good to seeary at some point, alright? Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Alright guys. Nice to meet you, Bill. Alright, nice to meet you guys too. See you, bye.
好吧，回头在演艺圈的餐厅见吧，好吗？是的，完全正确。好的，伙计们。很高兴认识你，比尔。好的，也很高兴认识你们。再见，伙计。好的，很高兴在某个时候在餐厅见面，好吗？是的，完全正确。好的，伙计们。很高兴认识你，比尔。好的，也很高兴认识你们。再见，拜。
Nice to meet you, Sean, I've met you before, and we'll, you know, see you. Yeah, I know, fuck it, yeah. We've had our moments. Alright, okay, bye-bye. We've had our moments, goodbye. Super fun. Bill Burr.
很高兴认识你，肖恩，我以前见过你，而且我们，你知道，回头见。是的，我知道，管他呢，是的。我们有过属于我们的时刻。好吧，好的，拜拜。我们有过属于我们的时刻，再见。超级有趣。比尔·伯尔。
Super fun. Now, we've been trying to boat that fish for a while. I think he's been on all of our lists, I'll bet you. Yeah, he has, and then he was gonna be on. I think he's been on all of our lists, I'll bet you. Yeah, he has. And then he was going to be on, I knew he was going to be on at one point, because I think I, I forget how I knew that. And I wanted to have him on,
超级有趣。现在，我们一直在试图钓那条大鱼好一阵子了。我敢打赌他一直在我们所有人的名单上。是的，他确实在，然后他要来。我敢打赌他一直在我们所有人的名单上。是的，他确实在。然后他要来，我知道他迟早会来，因为我想我，我忘了我是怎么知道的了。我想请他来，
and I've known him for a long time. And I really do love the guy, even though it seems like we're enemies. He's hilarious. I want to act with him. Yeah, he's really good. I think he's fun on set. Oh, I want to act with somebody.
而且我和他认识很久了。我真的很喜欢这家伙，尽管看起来我们像是敌人。他太搞笑了。我想跟他演对手戏。是的，他真的很棒。我觉得他在片场很有趣。哦，我想跟某人演对手戏。
I want to be with somebody. Act with somebody. I want to be with him. What was that, Whitney? Is that Whitney Houston? That is Whitney Houston, yeah. Jay, you never answered the question. I want to know what that was because last night I was thinking about it. Isn't it a weird thing to call action for the very first time in your life?
我想和某人在一起。和某人演对手戏。我想和他在一起。那是什么，惠特尼？那是惠特尼·休斯顿吗？那是惠特尼·休斯顿，是的。杰伊，你从来没回答那个问题。我想知道那是什么，因为昨晚我在想这件事。生平第一次喊“开拍”（action）不是很奇怪吗？
Because you've only heard it. I actually do remember that moment. Yeah, try it as a young punk at 18. Oh, really? Talking to a bunch of adults. Yeah, it was terrifying. Yeah, I was so, I just felt like such a fraud. Still do. No, you're brilliant.
因为你以前只听别人喊过。我其实还记得那个时刻。是啊，作为一个18岁的小混混去尝试。哦，真的吗？跟一群成年人说话。是的，太吓人了。是的，我太，我感觉自己就像个骗子。现在还是。不，你很才华横溢。
So he was great, I love him. I've been a fan for a long time. I did see, no, I realized why he lashed out to me. I did see him at Albert Hall and he was fucking great. He was awesome. He was absolutely destroyed. And he shot a special from there and he destroyed fucking great. He was awesome. He's absolutely destroyed and he shot a special from there and he destroyed and but he has a tough time taking a compliment.
所以他很棒，我爱他。我当他的粉丝很久了。我确实看到，不，我明白他为什么对我发飙了。我确实在阿尔伯特音乐厅看过他演出，他他妈的太棒了。他太厉害了。他简直状态爆棚。他在那儿录了一场特辑，他炸翻了场子，他他妈的太棒了。他太厉害了。他简直状态爆棚，他在那儿录了一场特辑，他炸翻了场子，而且他很难接受别人的赞美。
He's got a lot of issues that are great. Yeah, he seems like a good dude. He's a funny, funny, funny dude. He's one of the, he's again, he falls in that category of just like he has no choice. He's naturally funny. Yeah he's naturally funny, he's just funny. What are you guys gonna do the rest of the day? I've got a sign language lesson today. Oh, for um. Yeah, this job I've got coming up, I gotta do a little bit of sign language,
他有很多很棒的问题。是的，他看起来是个好人。他是个搞笑、搞笑、搞笑的家伙。他是那种，他又一次，他属于那种别无选择的人。他天生就很搞笑。是的，他天生就很搞笑，他就是搞笑。你们今天剩下的时间打算做什么？我今天有一节手语课。哦，为了，嗯。对，我接下来要接的这个工作，我得做一点手语，
so I have to learn how to speak with my hands. Wait, that was Black Rabbit too, with that guy, that character. Yeah, but my character didn't have to do it, but in this thing coming up, I gotta do a couple of scenes in sign language. And apparently- Do you know what this means?
所以我必须学会用双手交谈。等等，那也是《黑兔》，跟那个家伙、那个角色有关。对，但我的角色不需要这样做，但在接下来的这个节目里，我得用手语演几场戏。显然——你知道这是什么意思吗？
That's a fuck you. Now, Will, apparently I only need 15 hours of, you know, based on what little I have to do. To the bare minimum. Does that include portal to portal or? Exactly, but I'm so curious, because it's obviously, it's not word for word or verbatim. I'm so curious to learn just the first hour of what it,
那是去你的。现在，威尔，显然我只需要15个小时的，你知道的，基于我必须做的这一点点工作。达到最低标准。这包括门到门的时间吗？没错，但我太好奇了，因为这显然不是逐字逐句的。我很想知道仅仅前一个小时学的是什么，
because it's kind of paraphrasing in general words, I guess. I'll report back. What is this in sign language? Oh, that's bye! Bye! Bye! That's one of my favorites. That's nice, Shani. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armgerve, Bennett Barbico, and Michael Grand Terry. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
因为这大概是用通用词汇进行释义吧。我回头向大家汇报。这是手语里的什么？哦，那是再见！再见！再见！那是我最喜欢的之一。真不错，沙尼。SmartLess 由 Rob Armgerve、Bennett Barbico 和 Michael Grand Terry 100% 有机手工制作。本期节目暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。